Well,
hey fuckers,
ha ha
the shows on right now.
We're live tweeting at the
same time he bitches sweet,
sweet pitches. When I say bitches,
I mean that would no disrespect.
Some of my best friends are bitches.
Matter of fact,
all of them at one point in time
I've called a bitch. If I don't,
if I don't like call you
a bitch at one point,
bitch please or come on bitch.
You know what the fuck I'm talking about.
If I don't say that at least once in our
relationship, I don't feel close to you.
Do not see him talking, then we are
really tight. We're tight as fuck dude.
Bitch.
This episode of the Joe Rogan experience
is brought to you by legal zoom.
If you have a situation like
you want to become incorporated,
do you want to become an LLC?
You want to make a will. Uh,
you want to handle some
standard legal stuff.
Most of the time you got to go to a
lawyer, you got to make an appointment,
go somewhere, sit down, talk
to some dude or a woman,
give them a ton of money.
And it's very frustrating that you
can't handle that stuff on your own.
Legal Zoom though allows you to handle
most of those types of transactions.
Like will's like, uh,
becoming yellow, an LLC.
All those things you can do online. Naked.
Okay? You don't even have to be sober.
You could be playing with yourself.
You could have your cock in one hand
and a mouse and the other and no one can
stop you. Man. They can't tell you
what to do. They don't own you. Okay?
But if you go to,
there's silly little legal box,
the legal box, we have to say, hi,
the lady that sits at the desk and
once to fucking jump off a bridge,
you have to say,
how did that check bored out of her skull?
And then you have to give
up credit card information,
your address and your this and your that.
And then you wait for the guy to
let you in and then, oh Jesus.
And then somebody cops on you as SARS.
Oh, Brett Dunkin. That's not what happens.
Anyway, legal zoom.com go there
and check it out. Use the code.
J R e and save yourself some
money. Is it January? No.
Legal Zoom is rogue again.
Which ones? Jerry? Uh,
they really should all be universal
stamp dot coms Jerry. Yeah,
use a code name Brogan and save yourself
some money. It's an excellent service.
Brian is actually used it, although
I, you know, I wouldn't really
and really bring that up,
but they can do things for you and
they can also get you in touch with a
legitimate independent attorney if you
get like along the process and you know,
I've done this before with
certain things where you're a,
you're going over some fine print of
something and you're like, oh, okay,
I got to stop here.
I don't know what the fuck I'm doing this.
This shit just got deep. I just
wanted to deep water. Well if you,
if you feel that way,
legal zoom can connect you
with an independent attorney
and a legal team is not
a law firm.
They just offer you legal services
online that you could do yourself.
They will guide you through it.
But if you get confused,
they hook you up with an attorney.
Use a code name rogue and
save yourself some money.
We'll also brought to you by stamps.com
if you've ever been in those desk squad
kitty cat shirts at Brian red band cells
and there's a new one on the way out.
Uh, it's available right now for
presale. If you go a death squad.tv,
it's my favorite yet.
It's pretty dope malicious and it's a
much higher quality than the other ones
with uh,
the,
the ink is like printed into the shirt
itself instead of being like a plastic
decal. They're very cool. Brian
Cells, all of those himself does,
it makes them himself hasn't printed and
then actually sends them out himself.
So if you get a box from Brian, read
Ben, it's been touched by his DNA.
It might, it's, it's healthy. I mean
it's not, it's on dangerous DNA,
but you know you,
you could convict him or something if
you wanted to like take this box and he
licked things on there and you could say,
this motherfucker licked my ass and
just stick it on your ass and then go
directly to a doctor and then they swab
your ass with the cute. My point is
stamps.com is a simple way of sending
things through the mail with just using
your own personal computer and a printer.
Instead of going to the post office
with a box of shit that you're trying to
sell and have it all laid out,
you could do it all at home.
You also have a wonderful
opportunity to save some money.
If you click on the old school,
you microphone in the upper right
hand corner and use the code j. R.
E you get $115 value,
which is includes a free digital scale
and a $55 of a of postage postage credit.
It's an excellent service and it
makes things fun. It's a fun, hi.
It's fun to get stamps. Yeah,
yeah. Print it all up on your, uh,
your printer. That was Duncan
Trussell. He's, he's strange,
but I love him. Anyway,
you use the code j r e@stamps.com and
save yourself some money and excellent
service one that we fully endorse here
on the Joe Rogan experience podcast.
This episode is also brought to you by
on it. And this is the last sponsor,
I swear to the baby Jesus. Um,
on it. Makers of Alpha brain,
the cognitive nootropic subst.
Well,
I don't know if most people don't know
what the fuck you're talking about.
When you say new tropics,
when nootropics are,
is essentially vitamins that enhance
the way your brain functions.
It gives you all the fuel that you
need to create neurotransmitters,
the building blocks, if you will, a
very controversial stuff. Read up on it.
But one thing that I can tell you with
utmost confidence now is we've already
done the first in a series of double
blind placebo tests and had excellent
results with Alpha brain.
So that was a big relief because you
take something and even though you read a
bunch of shit that says
it does a really good,
and even though you're read all these
positive results and even though you read
even peer reviewed evidence about the
actual ingredients that are in Alpha brain
until you get your own
double blind placebo study,
people don't give a fuck about you.
Unfortunately it was only,
we did it with 20 people
and four dropped out.
It's enough to to have like a full blown
study. So we're going to do another one.
But the point is the results were
positive and it was done the correct way.
Double Blind Placebo Style and a,
it showed improvements in memory,
improvements in cognitive function.
We'll explain it all once the uh,
the piece is published,
but it's a huge weight off my back
and a lot of the people's back because
rightly so,
whenever someone comes out with something
that says that it's a brain enhancing
supplement,
people start thinking about all those big
Dick pills that you see and those porn
ads don't really work. You
start thinking about, oh,
a lot of other snake oil type situations.
I personally have been using
nootropics though for a long time.
I started out with a Roman
house skis neuro one. It's a, a,
a common atory a thing like this that
you mix it, you make a drink out of it.
And I, uh, I read about it and Bill Roman
[inaudible] who was a football player,
he started making that stuff,
uh,
and using nootropics after dealing with
head injuries from concussions from
football.
It's a fascinating topic that most
people are kind of ignorant about.
But if you're,
if you're interested in it,
I suggest you pursue it because there
is definitely some fruit at the end of
that tree. Um, we're also, um,
can I pipe in for a second?
Yeah.
I'm not sponsored by
on it for some reason.
I don't know what I did do
it Venda on it company. So,
but I can honestly say because I have
no financial stake at all. In fact,
I've been rejected by
the company that I love.
I take Alpha brain and what Joe won't say,
is it speed?
It's just, it's good speed.
It's like low level Adderall.
I don't get that at all. I don't get
that at all. It's not, that's not what
the function of the nutrients inside of
it or, or you know, like designed to do.
Yeah, it gives me a very good,
when I say speed, I don't mean bad.
I mean that's good.
It's like a nice buzz.
You take it and you feel awake.
I like taking it a all day when I have it.
I go through the jars within three
days. They're just gone. Well,
it gives you weird
dreams. Oh fuck man. My,
I took a nap today that was like Jacob's
ladder taking Alpha brain and I swear I
was in it,
an airplane sucking on
the feet of this woman.
She was flying the plane. Yeah. And I was
like laying on dirt, sucking her feet.
I had an offer for
brain dream the other day. Uh, I tweeted
about it. It was about Bobby Collins.
The comedian was doing a talk show out
of his apartment and in the opening
montage of his talk show is Sam Kinison
his comb over and it's flying around the
air, getting pelted by meteors
while it's flying around,
just like explosions.
His comb overs flying around in the sky
and the meteors are hitting his comb
over. It was the most nonsensical,
ridiculous. You can't make this up dream.
And I woke up in the middle of it because
my alarm went off and it was one of
those where it's like, you're right
in the middle rem sleep and you'll,
your alarm wakes up and you're like, what
the fuck? Yeah, that is good. I don't,
I think that was one of the best
pieces of at least anecdotal evidence.
Alpha brain actually was working
that was doing something was the,
the uniformity of the reports of people
saying that it affected their dreams in
a very radical way. Why are you
making everything Paul Pink? Uh,
go to [inaudible] dot com it's a lot of
the shit we sell, including Kettlebells,
these primal bells that,
or kettle bells with a awesome
designs carved into them.
We hired a special effects designer
to make an angry, angry chimp.
We've got a gorilla coming out soon.
We've got a a bunch of a really
cool designs in the future.
We sell a bunch of healthy shoots
that's tossed around. We sell powders.
It enhances your body's ability to
produce testosterone. All of these things.
Also,
all these controversial things.
They're all explained with science and
references on on [inaudible] dot com use
the code name Brogan.
Save 10% off Duncan trussell's here
and were fin to get our free gone.
Hello.
Hey pitches.
Oh,
good experience.
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
Ooh,
Nice. So that worked all
day. Did the show all day.
And this never feels like work. This
always feels like, ah, the podcast,
the podcast. It's nothing. It's not work.
I mean, it isn't. It isn't. It's never,
I mean,
if you start thinking this is work,
there's going to be a lot of coal miners.
You think your toxic
Duncan Trussell on TV today. Oh,
crazy. Yeah. Kind of freaking out it.
I thought you would handle it well,
but you're not. You kind of tricking,
tweaking a little bit.
I'm excited. How do I not be
excited about this? I'm just fine
with, you know, you're
handling it very well. I mean,
it's exciting and it's like a thank
you for getting me on the show.
Thanks for doing it. You may
of that. That's a cool thing.
Manda usher uh, your friends into
something like that. Cause it's,
it's, so, it's been such a freakish
year for me, man. You know,
it's like in the beginning was fucked up.
Balls snipped off for folks who don't
know, you got cancer of your balls,
ball got snipped. They took one of
your testicles home. They threw it. Oh,
I always wonder where it is.
It's going to cat's litter box somewhere.
But it's great because the year culminated
in being out in the Pacific northwest
with you.
Hi.
As a fucking
watching hunting for Sasquatch,
it really was like, well this is great
man. This is like a one. This is,
this is definitely one of the coolest
years of my life. That was so fun.
It was so fun. It really is. It's like
we've sort of, we've made this
life inside of a simulation.
Like it doesn't make any sense.
Like when you actually have
a job where you get to go.
Like we went Utah last week looking
for Ufos and giant bulletproof wolves.
These people,
they see wolves that turn into messed
and disappear and the fucking show up on
top of barns. The size of a horse. Yeah.
Bulletproof wolves. The size of a horse.
We're, we're having so much
fun. It's so ridiculous.
Like we're talking to so many crazy
people and so many really interesting like
sciencey people too.
Yeah. It's so fun to be
around, that's for sure man.
It's definitely spun me
around in a lot of ways.
It's helped me understand how
religions starts. It's helped me.
I go stand delusion.
Yeah.
It's helped me understand that part of
myself that is delusional or the part of
myself that uh, is either too
eager to disbelieve something,
are too eager to believe something. Like
that's where my pendulum swings. Right?
Like, and in that middle place, people
don't like that middle place places. Yeah.
People don't like it there, you know?
Cause that middle place is the mystery.
People don't like that feeling. That's
why I live. Yeah. That's my spot. Yeah.
I think it's cool to get there, but God
dammit, it's like that's no fun. I mean
be there with my life too though. I like
to be there with my life. I like to be,
that's one of the reasons why I do so
many different things. At the same time,
I don't like to be comfortable that much.
I mean I like too comfortable
in friendships and I
like to be comfortable in
relationships. But as far as like
work stuff and life stuff and and,
and my pursuits,
whether it's a competition or exercising,
I don't like to be comfortable.
I think that's, that's the enemy.
I like to be plenty comfortable when
I'm at home and I'm lounging, yeah,
I'm chilling with my family or
I'm hanging with my friends.
I love being comfortable then.
But other than that I don't like it.
So like when it, when it comes with an
idea, like an idea of what is or isn't,
what is or isn't possible, that middle
spot of the pendulum where it's all weird.
That's my favorite spot because I like
when you're in a situation and people go
big foot, you believe in big foot and
then you bring a guy like Jeff Meldrum,
that guy that we talked to,
the anthropologist who is,
you know, you've got a phd,
an expert in human movement.
And he starts explaining things like the
metatarsal break that you find in these
footprints that indicates it's
built like a gorilla's foot,
not like a human foot because
human beings don't have,
and then you see this break
and he demonstrates it and
then you start going, huh,
you're talking to a fucking smart dude.
The believes his shit. Like this is weird.
Yeah. And then we asked him if we'd be
willing to cut off a pinky. Oh yeah. Toe.
I, yeah. Got Weird. You have
to watch the show Dunkin.
I can't have to wash the shaking
and watch myself on TV. Oh, you can.
You were great. Uh, the, uh, the,
that place is a very zen
place, man. That's like,
why this a Zen Roshi I met when
I went on this Rom doss retreat.
That's what she kept saying again,
again, is live in the mystery.
That's where we belong, is in the
mystery. It's, you don't, you can't,
you're not going to know
what happens after you die.
You're not going to figure that out.
And the place of like the Zen place or
the Buddhist or the nonattached place to
be as a place where you are,
it's not that you don't know or do know,
it's some other state of just,
I guess being at the crest of the wave
of the universe articulating itself and
as you,
yeah, and what's important when I say
that I like to be in the ministry, what I,
what I really mean like that about that
is if it's a mystery and there's some
shifts, it's not a mystery at all.
And that's also a part of the thing.
It's recognizing what is an actual
ministry. And when you do find it,
like the nature of reality,
if you get to one of those weird ones,
the possibility of a universal power
that's controlling the world and moving it
into a certain direction.
The idea that this is all some sort of
a mathematical program and that good and
evil and sex and love and all
this different shit, good and bad,
all sort of make sure that this thing
keeps moving. That's the real mystery.
It's not chem trails. Okay. You know
what I'm saying? Like it's, it's not,
it's not ghosts. The real me.
There's plenty of mystery.
The real mystery is does every decision
that you make literally branch off and
start a whole new reality and a
whole universe that you live in?
Because sometimes it feels
like that and I'm not sure,
and I don't think you're sure either.
When someone tells me they're sure or are
shorts not, are they sure there? Sure.
It is either one of those. It's
unacceptable because you can't be sure.
There's things that you can't be shoring.
Those things are really weird and it's
hard to get comfortable in those things.
It's hard to get comfortable,
like holding on,
holding on to those ideas and like and
pondering them because a lot of them,
the implications they, they, they
transfer through your entire life.
The implications are, well if you really
are building up a career and bill,
but you're,
you're,
you're just a part of the ether and you're
part of like some sort of a gigantic
super organism. Like why are you
concentrating so much on yourself?
Like why are you twisting your
mustache at the end with wax? Why you,
why you doing this? Why
you buying, you know,
$2,000 shoes that you hope somebody
notices? Why are you, you know,
what are you doing? W what,
what is going on? Yeah.
Are those things distracting
you from the mystery,
you know? Well, I mean
it seems like there's two parts
to a person, which is the, the,
the part that is the personality that
conditioning everything you've learned,
all the, all the tricks that
you've learned from other
people. A lot of imitation,
you know,
a lot of observing things in the,
imitating them and forgetting
that you imitated them.
There's probably personality and
components in us that we picked up in the
fourth grade from some kid we thought
was cool and just forgot about it and it
stuck inside of us. And so then there's
this idea that we're kind of like, uh,
the human body itself is a hive and it
is a hive that within which dwell all
these different bees and the bees
are all the different aspects of our
personality.
We're not one person.
We're a harmony of personalities that
are always sort of through cause like if
you think of the you and you're really
pissed off whenever you're yelling at
someone or in a state where you find
yourself in a confrontational place and
then you think of the you and you're
chilling at home with your family,
that's like two different people,
you know.
And so that's the idea is that there's
all these different parts of us that are
rolling through all the time,
always rolling through and that we
are constantly working to uphold the
continuity of being by acting
in certain ways all the time.
And quite often you'll hear us like if
you're in a relationship or something,
someone will say like,
I don't know you anymore.
It was this person you know and it's
because really what they're seeing is the
other one something,
one of the other dominant personalities
that lives inside of you that starting
to poke its head out every once in
awhile and people that don't have a good
transition between those.
Those are the people we call multiple
personality disorder people. Yes, exactly.
And how many, how many Abby's are
in there with you Abby? Yeah man.
That's what it is and when those,
when those in and you see are,
when people say that they're channeling
or when people are demon possessed,
really what's happening is one of these
personalities that is gotten shoved way
deep down in the dark part of the hive
is managed to claw it's way out and it's
so different than all the other
ones that people are like,
this guy has got a demon in
him when really the truth
is we're just this cluster
of of selves that are all sort
of like the way it's been. This,
I heard there's this mystic
named Gurdjieff who described
it as like a mansion
where all the servants are running amok.
So it's a mansion where all the servants
who were supposed to have certain jobs
and certain areas where they work in the
mansion of just lost and forgotten what
they're supposed to be doing.
They're all going crazy.
And so then modern person is wandering
around with this kind of constant,
chaotic stream of personalities
that aren't disciplined in any way.
And so the beginning of spiritual
life for the beginning of discipline,
martial arts, whatever the thing is, is
where the master of the house returns.
And that's considered the
personality that develops.
Once you control all those
different facets of the self,
and that's what you become is the
master of the House who's gone away.
And while he was away,
all of the servants went nuts.
That's what happens when you get drunk
like gay, the mass design here. Woo.
Yeah. There were over your
face [inaudible] tags.
Yeah. Where's my keys? Yeah.
And it's also why you have to
be compassionate to people.
If someone around you
has been a dick to you.
So you know some really stupid people
when someone's addicted them will never
forgive them for the rest of your life.
You'd be like,
you remember the time you said that to
me? Oh, you know, and it's like, well,
that was just a part of me that came out.
That's not me.
That's not the totality of me.
That's just somebody made who managed
to get to the window and scream,
scream something. That's a real problem.
Those people that want to bring up,
that happened a long
time ago over and over and over again.
Oh.
And just always use it as a button to
get sympathy. Like, that's not good.
That's not healthy for you.
It's not healthy for them.
It's not healthy for anybody. Like people
that can't let certain things. I mean,
there's certain things you
shouldn't let go. You know?
Like if you were in a concentration
camp and Hitler killed your family,
you'd be like, Hey Dick,
you know my family.
But if you're like,
you know,
if you yelled at someone because he didn't
want to get up and take out the trash,
like let's you know,
let that go.
Yeah, you got to let it go. Mostly you
gotta just let it go if you can. It's,
it's hard though man.
I mean I,
I ruminate over shit that people
have done to me sometimes.
Like I'll find myself from ruminating it,
which is such a waste,
such a waste of time.
Dude, I had Graham Hancock,
I skyped with Graham Hancock on my
podcast today. Oh that's beautiful.
Blew my mind man. He like,
that guy is so God damn smart.
He's got a book out now, a fiction
book called War War War Guy. Yeah.
And he's really excited about it
when he starts talking about history.
It's amazing cause you feel like you're
with somebody who is actually lived
during that time when he was
describing like a Mayan sacrifices.
When he starts talking about that, it's
not like reading it in a history book.
Like when he talks about the jagged
Flint tools to slice open the chest.
I'm not even doing it. I get why? Don't
know what acronyms, terrible accident.
But he, yeah, the thing he
was talking about today, and
it was, I, it was, you know,
inspired from talking about his
book is this idea a gnostic idea,
which is,
uh,
gnosticism is this weird philosophy
that believes that the god that everyone
worships currently, uh, and, and all the
different religions, the Christian God,
the, uh, Muslim God,
any God that's being worshiped is actually
an evil force known as the demiurge.
It's something that
is, uh, actually Satan.
So the thing that the Christians are the
thing that whispers in the Christians
ear, that it's time to go to war or the
thing that convinces some uninstall omic
terrorist,
a strap,
plastic explosives to his chest
and go running into a cafe.
It's like an evil force
that's been controlling the
planet and manipulating the
people on the planet by pretending to
be a god and causing them to do insane
things. Where's this concept come
from? Not, it's called gnosticism.
Well, I know at Gnosticism is,
but this concept of that is from,
yeah, and that's the demiurge
and the demiurge created humans.
So humans are all the
children of the demiurge.
Humans are the children of this force,
which is kind of the spirit of matter
that is all about dominance and fear,
right?
Troll what a crazy idea.
And that's why people like
overwhelmingly throughout human history,
there's never been a period of time
where no one's done anything evil ever.
There's never been a period of
time as far we can tell as far
as written history,
there's never been a period of time
where nobody controlled anybody.
Nobody hit anybody, nobody murdered
anybody. And then we stole anything.
Nobody raped anybody,
nobody beat their kids.
There's never been one time where like
nothing happened bad for like a year.
Everybody was just hugs
and love and kisses.
But yet we hold on to this idea that well,
people were mostly good.
We're basically good. Yeah,
peaceful in their hearts.
All people are basically good.
But if you look at the totality of the,
the behavior of human beings and you
factor in the time of utmost piece to time
of ultimate peace,
it's a zero.
There's 0% ultimate peace in
the totality of the human race.
It's never happened. Yup,
that's right. You occasionally
get that in the household.
You occasionally get that in a community
where there's just a mild disagreements.
They tried to keep it to a little bit
of Shit, talking behind people's back,
you know? But then as you spread
out and he'd get into cities,
there's no cities where nobody gets
robbed. No, they don't exist in religion.
Communities want to talk about
some fucking stink holes. Dude,
I'm reading this book by Jon Krakauer
called under the banner of Heaven,
which is about fundamentalist Mormons.
Do you know about this? No. Whew.
Holy Shit. Does that like the
Jeffries Guy? Yeah, there's it.
I think so. The Jeffries,
which was the Jeffries Guy,
was the guy that goes, just got
arrested. He was the polygamists.
Yes, yes, yes. Yeah. It's, so
here's the way it works. There is,
in this book it talks about,
I can't remember the town,
but there is an area that
is run completely by a guy
named Uncle Ruan or was run
by this guy named uncle rule on who
is a Mormon fundamentalist. This,
these are, these people
are rejected by the, uh,
mainstream Mormons because the
government came in at one point and said,
you guys can't be polygamous.
It's illegal. And so they
had to renounce polygamy.
And this was something that
according to this book,
Joseph Smith said was
the essence of Mormonism.
It's still one of the most deepest,
most important parts of Mormonism
is that you have multiple,
or what they call a plurality of wives,
morality. That's good learning. So,
and here's the thing.
This is why you need a bunch of wives.
If you are a fundamentalist Mormon,
you are only supposed to have sex
with your wife when she's ovulating.
Which means if you only have one wife,
you're not only going to have sex
a few times a month, once a month.
I don't know how women ovulate
once a month. If you have 15 wives,
you can fuck every night.
So it's very important to have as many
wives as possible because then you could
have sex with them all the time.
And they're always humping.
And a lot of these guys have so
many children. They, one of the,
I can't remember which one it was.
It might've been uncle Ruan.
I can't remember which one had so many
children that they named them according
to the year. So if you were born in like
1979 you are, your name would have an ae.
So it'd be like an about Angus Ari.
And then you would,
what year your kid was born in by
the first letter of his name. Wow.
That's how many kids are having.
So then you have girls and your girls
get to be the age of 14 and you've got a
pal. Like if I had a 14 year old kid
and I was a fundamentalist Mormon,
I feel like, Joe, why don't
you marry my daughter Laurie?
She just started bleeding and then I
would give her to you and you would
immediately start fucking her.
And so that's what they're
doing out there. It's like,
it's just like just herds and packs
of pregnant teenagers that have been
impregnated by these older
dudes who have so many wives.
And this shit is, I think it's
still going on today, man.
There's whole communities dedicated
to this polygamist lifestyle,
which is a lifestyle that Joseph Smith
said was one of the most important
aspects of Mormonism according to this
book. The other thing about Joseph Smith,
do you know what he did before
he found he founded Mormonism?
What he was what was called like a
treasure seeker and so you would use magic
stones to peer through to that would show
you our secret treasure was buried and
he,
there was a huge lawsuit against him
because he convinced all these people that
he could find Berridge pressure.
That was also what he said about the
golden tablets. Yeah, that was it.
He could use a seer stone and
see it through a magic rock.
That's how he could read the golden
tablets before he was doing the seer stone
and the angel a mower Moroni before
he's using the seer stone and the Angel
Moroni came to him. He was
actually getting work convincing
people like, hey look,
I've got a magic rock and there
and I can find your silver for you.
Because there was like a guy who hired
him because he knew that there was some
silver hidden up in the hills somewhere
and Joseph Smith went around with like
wards looking through the courts and
finally after like three months of hiring
him by the month, they took him
to court and they're like, hey,
this guy can't really find
treasure with that. Rock me. Well,
he's out there looking every day.
Wouldn't you have loved to seen like a
video of him talking of Joseph Smith,
like talking and explaining his strategies
and what he does and you know what
Mormonism is all about. Yeah,
man. I mean, exactly. I just love,
I just love that idea of like,
uh,
that here's a man who was, look, come on,
let's just admit it.
Here's a man who's like,
just basically like a classic
con artists. Come on, man.
You're really telling people you
can find treasure with a rock.
No one's ever found treasure.
That's something like when I was in the
third grade that I would lie about to a
kid in the playground or something,
but this guy was making money off of it.
It's just very interesting to
see something grow roots and,
and flourish in the way that
that Mormonism has when,
when just with a very simple
investigation end of the, uh,
you've got lawsuits, there's written
records against Joseph Smith. Yeah.
Cause he was taken to court for lying.
No, no, no, no, no. But the angels really
did take the golden tablets. He really,
he really is the, the one he really
did find the loss work of Jesus.
He really can look at
it with a magic rock.
And for him it was always a magic
rock. Yeah. Magic rock. That was his,
that was his angle. It magic rocks.
But meanwhile, when we were in Utah,
we were in Utah the other day and
docking and I show up and when we arrive,
there was these hordes of people that
were waiting for these elders and the
elders of the young kids that
go away on a mission. Yeah.
All Mormons when they're
young or they're old,
they're supposed to go on these recruiting
missions as elders where they go,
they wear a suit and tie and they go to
third world countries or wherever they
go. Some of them go to third
world countries and they
recruit people and so these
guys were returning from their missions
and they were all like dolled up in
their finest suits and what their ties
on and when they showed up people just
scream and cheer and it was for Dunkin.
I was so strange because we were like
these weird heretics that are walking
through them were high.
We've got coffee in our hands.
They're not even allowed to drink
coffee. And so by the way, by the way,
by the way,
they're also one of the highest per capita
users of antidepressants because the
fact they're not allowed to drink
and not allowed to take coffee.
They are allowed to take
prescription medications. So weird.
They just chomped at shit.
Isn't that weird? Yeah, it's really weird.
Especially when when like sober people
like people who are like really into
being into sobriety or like chomping
on like Xanax and shit. And it's like,
what's the why? What's the difference
between that and booze? Really?
I know a woman who criticizes pot on
a regular, but she's very ignorant.
She Criticizes Pod, she takes his
Xanax every night to go to sleep.
She cannot sleep without a Xanax.
She'll take a Xanax and
that's how she goes to sleep.
Yeah, man, I, it's a really confused,
that's a very confusing issue.
Drugs are bad. I, that's why I love
Terence Mckenna's breakdown of that,
where he's like,
come on every morning we
are brewing a fucking drug.
We wake up every morning and we haven't
machines designed to extract alkaloids
from coffee beans that we put into our
bloodstream before we go to work every
morning. And that's not looked down
as strange at all. And not only that,
every labor contract is negotiated
with a break for this drug in it.
The coffee break. Yeah, but that doesn't
count. So when you tell people like, wait,
no,
really the entire planet or this it
North America wakes up slurps back a drug
every morning just to get ready to
go to their jobs and then they take,
what are they called?
Coffee breaks and coffee breaks.
If you were telling me like, Hey,
I'm going to go take a cocaine break,
do you mind if I call you gotta you
gotta fucking problem. Well, how about
fact that they're taking Xanax to go
to sleep and then they get drunk on the
weekend?
Well, yeah, you add on top of it that
they're getting drunk. They're taking, uh,
Xanax and pets. Very popular
nowadays. It's very popular.
I understand why it's, have you done
it? Yeah. What's it like? It's awesome.
You just like go to instantaneous,
like an instant relaxed. I'm trying to,
okay. Like, let me, I'll try to
think of a description of it. Okay.
Think about a night when you've had a
really good show and you wake up the next
morning and you're laying in bed, you've
had a good sleep, you're not hung over.
And it that dawning realization like,
man, that was a good show last night,
but you're still relaxed and
laying in bed and you're like, ah,
that's what Xanax does. Fau. Yeah,
just it's like the opposite
of any kind of anxiety or uh,
any kind of like tightening up.
You might have it gets rid of
that, but I've noticed that, uh,
there's a bit of a residual effect
with it. It's not a clean drug.
At least it hasn't been for me where
like a couple of days after you take it,
you feel kind of greasy and weird.
And when I've taken Xanax,
I've gotten the hiccups,
which is really strange. Yeah.
I'll start like having like Xanax hiccups.
The way I've heard it
bribed is that you, it, it, it
alleviates a lot of your anxiety,
but then it's almost like a rubber band.
It like snaps back.
It gives you more anxiety than you had
before. Um, my friend who takes it,
he tells me he has,
he takes it almost every day and
he can't get along without it.
He needs it like for anxiety.
He tells me when he gets off of it,
he gets really freaked out.
What the fuck is anxiety, man?
I, that's the reality. Yeah.
The reality of your life, the reality
of your body. This guy who, uh, is uh,
addicted to it, he takes
it every day. He's also a,
he's also overweight and he
also drinks too much. Right.
He's got issues and so he, I don't think
he likes to address those issues. Right.
And so instead of addressing those issues,
he says he has anxiety.
Man. There are certain things though that
were where anxiety is unavoidable, man.
I like,
I just think there's certain times that
emerge in your life where anxiety is not
all a lot of the time it's an
indication that you're fucking up. Yes.
But sometimes it's just a natural
reaction to life. It's so high.
Yeah.
Life itself. The inevitability of your
demise. There's no getting around it.
You know, the, the,
the ruthlessness of the day to day
grind can also give you anxiety.
The idea that even though it's Friday
and you're off of work, oh my God,
I'm going to have to go back there on
Monday and I'm gonna work eight to nine
hours, whatever I have to
do, including overtime,
and then I'm going to do it again
on Tuesday and then on Wednesday,
and then on Thursday,
and then Friday again,
and then I'm gonna get
a little break again.
And during that break I
got a lot of shit to do.
So it's not really a break and that just
that alone, as it accumulates over time,
then you start to,
you start to accumulate bills and you
start to accumulate responsibilities,
social responsibilities, responsibilities,
and the pressure of all that. Ken,
for Rick, you the fuck out
because it's a never ending.
Just a, a line of ants that goes on for
millions of miles. They're all tasks.
Every, every ant that you see
in front of you, every dot.
Every just like a million pages
is all things you have to do,
things you have to read. And it never
ends. If you have a job, a regular job,
especially, that's one of the reasons why
you should never, if you can avoid it,
never have a job. I mean, if you
need to have a job, get a job,
but if you could find something that
you love to do, you don't have a job,
then what you are is a lucky fuck. Yeah.
And then what you have is a cool gig.
You know,
like whether if you're a comedian or a
chef or a carpenter or something you love,
you know, a guy who builds motorcycles,
he loves it. He goes to work on grammar.
Yes. Anybody who loves
doing what they're doing,
that truly is the key to this life. And
everybody's just going to be different.
Your love is going to be different
than my love. You can't really judge,
can't judge what people like,
what they don't like.
You can judge what you like
and don't like, but you know,
it's like music tastes or tastes in food
or anything. Things are weird. You know,
things are weird and we vary wildly.
But yeah.
Yeah. The, the, the uh,
what I want to mention,
the idea I've been thinking about of uh,
um,
uh, it's called a temporal,
temporal peripheral vision,
temporal,
the temporal periphery.
So like humans develop peripheral vision
to deal with the predators so that it's
something to two at the, to our
side we could see a Predator coming.
And so we have this kind of like
side view that helps us out.
It's a very important thing.
Some animals don't have that.
They can only look straight forward,
right? But we have a, we're,
we can see off to the side a little
bit and that's a super important
evolutionary trait. Well, we also have
the exact same thing in the sense that,
but it's a temporal
peripheral vision where are,
we can think about the past and
we can think about the future.
And anxiety is always related to things
that we're looking at in the temporal
periphery. Nine Times out of 10, if
you come into the present moment,
you won't feel anxious.
You could be sitting in a doctor's
office about to go get your cat scan.
And if you could really pull yourself
just into the moment and what's happening
there, you wouldn't be,
you'd be 90% less afraid.
But the moment you step past that
sliver of the present moment,
that light beam and end of
the darkness of the future,
that's where the anxiety
pounds your fucking ass, man.
It's like touching an electric fence.
It's because things are always fine.
If you really look at it,
things are always fine.
Up until the Zombie rips your
intestines out of your stomach,
things are generally pretty
okay. You know that. That's the,
so that's the real conundrum. And
I think that's the, uh, the, um,
the thing that is so perplexing about
it being a human being, as you know,
that you're carrying around with you.
The ultimate,
which is the present moment,
but you can't stay in it.
You don't have the discipline
to stay there fully.
You're always wandering
off into the future,
always wandering off into what you
have to do, what's coming tomorrow,
what's coming in the next few minutes.
You know what I mean? It's so curious.
That right there in front
of us is the ultimate Xanax.
Well that's why the the shallow
feelings of materialism, you know,
what is materialism?
Well it's fixating on objects to fill
up your attention span for fixating on
them instead of all the other shit that
you could be thinking about instead of
you. You're your own designing your
own personal philosophy for life,
finding out what you like and don't
like about your past behavior and
incorporating it into the present.
Living in that moment,
being aware of what's
happening and managing it
correctly. All that's too much.
So you start thinking about the future.
I'd love to have a house that's like
6,000 square feet and I want to have 50
acres of land. I want to be on top of a
mountain and I want to have gun ports,
you know, start, you just start counting
points. You know what I'm saying?
You start like thinking about shit.
Cause if those motherfuckers come,
I'm going to be ready.
And instead of like being like right
there in that moment or you start thinking
about you know what a piece of shit you
were when you were a little kid and he
used to yell at your mother.
You mean you could start thinking about
weird shit and it could fill up your
present and it's part of being a human
being is managing the thought that that
you hold on to managing what you,
what you gravitate towards.
It's so hard to do if you
just got fired from a job,
it's very difficult to see the silver
lining you like shit. You just,
that feeling of getting just fucking
kicked out of a job and someone doesn't
want you work. Then when you are a failure
you failed and you're like, Oh God,
it's so hard to go. Come on,
let's go and have a good time.
Like you don't want to have a good time.
You feel fucking terrible
that much because it's also,
there's a dance going on, a
balancing act, if you will.
And that balancing act is you got to
learn from the fuck ups and the only way
you really learn is to
feel like shit and you,
it's best if you feel like shit for a
while because then it really sinks in.
The can't show up an hour late every day.
You can't smell like whiskey
after your lunch break.
You can't yell at your boss
because you're, you know,
you've got to have a hangover
and you're crabby that day.
You can't do those things
because you can get fired.
And when you get fired at fucking sucks.
But every time I've ever gotten fired
in my whole life, why fucked up?
And I got fired. I made like an
evolutionary jump as a person after that.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Every stupid thing that I've ever done
that's resulted in disaster has always
made me a million times better.
And why is that?
Because you have a terrible feeling
and you don't want to have that feeling
again. So it's forcing you to really
focus on whatever the hell it is.
Well, this is the, this is the, this is,
I mean it's something that you
don't want to accept. You know,
you want it to be,
you want the universe to be
something that's more or something
that's that that's more compassionate,
but it really does seem
like a huge portion of what
makes people great is their
ability to overcome internal difficulties
or external difficulties andF and
failure and, and, and that's something
that wouldn't, you're failing.
It won't give you any, it won't help you
when you're failing thinking like, oh,
this is,
I guess this is helping me.
I guess it does relieve some of the
pain of the thing when you realize that
you're in a kiln and you're
the failures that heat,
that sort of transforming
you into something.
Yeah. There's, I think that
it's, the feelings are there,
are they have they serve
like an evolutionary purpose
or a purpose that's in
line with progress.
A purpose that's in line with moving
forward and taking things to a next level,
which is why where we
always feel at at our best.
I always find that one of the reasons
why I try to like do like a lot of things
at once as cause I like figuring things
out and I like when things get better.
I like when a joke that I'm
working on becomes better.
I like when it grows and becomes real.
Not like when you write something down
then you add to it and then it becomes
better. I like getting better at a
skill, like a martial art or a game.
I love getting, I love getting better at
video games. It's a great feeling. Yeah,
and if you're not getting
better at things, if you're not,
if you don't have some sort
of improvement in movement,
if that's not the general trend
that you find your life in,
I find that I don't feel happy. I find
that that greatly affects my happiness.
And I also find that's one of the most
difficult things to achieve if and when
you have a job that you don't
enjoy because the majority
of your time and focus
during the day, they take all your best
hours. Man, you think about what a job is,
a nine to five they take the
hours that you are the most awake,
the most tuned in, the most aware
of, the most focused on the world.
So if you want to figure out
how to get out of your job,
you got to take your weakest time.
That's all they give you.
They give you your time where you're
the most tired and most likely to sit in
from the TV and the most likely to just
have a beer the most likely to take a
nap. They give you those
times and they say, all right,
you want to get out of this
fucking system. Here's your time.
Well,
this is why I like chanting and I think
chanting is a fantastic tool that you
can use in those times because chanting
something that you can do at work to get
fired. No, you do it in your
mind. You don't say it out loud,
but in your mind you can
start doing a mantra. Um,
you definitely don't have
to say mantras out loud.
You could just say it in your mind
so that, uh, in the midst of, uh,
when stress comes,
you can actually start training yourself
to start doing a mantra inside of your
mind and said, cause normally can't
do that if you're working. Sure.
If you have to interact with people
and you have a good deal while you're
talking to people, I'm doing it right
now. I could do it right now. My mind,
I can definitely write down how are
you doing that if you're going to
concentrate on what you're doing because
it's something. Yeah. Can you give Audis?
Yeah. Can you, can you what,
which Duncan, am I talking to
you right now? Can you, um,
do you think you could give
something your full attention,
like a job while you were chanting in
the back of your head at the same time?
Honestly, the next time you find yourself
in the midst of like working, you know,
doing some mundanity and of your
whatever it is, right? Watch,
become mindful and you will see that
some percentage of us focused on the task
at hand. But then another part of you
is always thinking, always thinking,
always processing,
always a whole other conversation is
always going on in people's minds.
It's an inevitability, you know, and some
people have more focused than others,
but in general there's always that,
uh,
that part of the mind that's like
an electric wire and a puddle.
There's just sort of skipping around
and spraying out random thoughts.
Well that's the part of your bind,
that chance,
that's the part of your mind
that you begin to train to
start doing it. A mantra,
which is like a simple mantra.
So that that thing, if you can,
instead of it being like,
ah man,
what the fuck got out of the cat scan
doesn't mean I have cancer. Jesus Christ,
man, I wish my ges was wider. I fucking
hate that song or whatever. Whatever.
Here you, whatever your mind
is stupidly spraying up,
you start training that when you can.
They would go
rom mom, mom, mom, mom,
and you read it. It's like throwing a
dog. A bone. What? What? Why Rom Rom Ron.
Was it just a sound? Just bad? It's
a mantra that people recommend.
It's cause it's got the on minute,
but it also has this nice
little are that you can wrong,
wrong,
wrong.
Do you think that people who have
like ADHD or isn't Ada, which, which,
which is the one that the guy on his
deathbed said isn't real? Is it Adhd?
Like add is real, but the guy who
created the Adhd said it was bullshit.
I don't know. Yeah, that's it's
Adhd is that one? Yeah. What did,
what was exactly what happened? He
was on his deathbed. He's like, ah.
I was just bullshitting.
Yeah. I wonder if he was being serious
about it or if it was just because he was
crazy. How is fucked? Right, right.
Yeah.
What,
what is the difference to add his
attention deficit disorder and Adhd,
attention deficit hyperactivity disorder,
isn't it? How much of the, I mean, how,
how accurate is their prognosis
or the diagnosis of add?
Because so often they're dealing
with kids and kids are bored as fuck,
you know,
and it's not because they have a disease.
It's because you're making them
do something boring as fuck.
Like I know because I have children,
I watch how how they
develop as like little,
little people sort of learning
how to get through things.
It's difficult for them to sit down.
They got fucking energy.
They want to dance and play and have fun.
They want to throw things and,
and wrestle with each other and play.
When you make them sit,
even if they're 10 or 12 there's
still juiced up with life.
And if you make them sit and just
do things, they get fucking bored.
And they know that what they're
doing is not as fun as baseball.
They know what they're doing is not
as fun as the video game that they're
addicted to.
They know it's not as fun as playing
with their friends when school's over so
they can't wait to get the
fuck out of there. And then you say,
well this boy has got a disease. Well,
no they don't.
You're,
you're offering them shit sandwiches and
they're not hungry. Yeah, no shit. I,
and that's why I think it's a funny term,
attention deficit disorder because these
kids, there's no deficits in attention.
There's uh, there's uh, maybe a,
it's a attention control disorder in the
sense that they can't control what they
focus their mind on.
I know I have an attention control this
order because I can be sitting on my
porch and then like look down at my phone
and not look up for another 15 minutes.
Okay,
but stop right there because you don't,
because if it's something that
you really love, like starcraft,
you can fucking lock on
to that shit for hours.
You can tune in with 100%
of your being for hours.
That's not an attention deficit disorder.
What you have is a love of starcraft,
which you have is you find the one thing
that you do just fucking really vibe on
and you chase after that five on
sounded very seventies. No, it's true.
Mantle family on everybody. But I think
that it's a, I, if I had my, if I could,
I would much rather, and maybe this
is an impossibility or fantasy,
but I'd much rather have the ability to
lock my attention on anything I wanted
to with the exact same level that
gets locked on to things that I enjoy.
Because I think if I could do
that, then I would be able to. Uh,
but you can, if you actually enjoy
it, if you actually enjoy it, you can.
Yeah. But certain things like books, uh,
like especially like really long novels.
Like I'm just listening to the stand,
the Stephen King audio, but Stan,
or it's good, but I'll tell
you the first like two hours,
there's a lot of shit in
there that doesn't involve
people coughing up sprays of
thick briny plague mucus and wandering
through an apocalyptic wasteland.
There's just a lot of character
development. That's not that fun, right?
But you need,
you need to focus on that because it
brings the characters to life more a
Kendall's the fire of the story. So
it's like sir, you know, and also,
uh, running, you know,
and I go jogging the first 30 minutes
or 20 minutes aren't exactly a blast.
Like my mind is going everywhere.
But then this thing will kick in
where suddenly you're like, ah,
this is fucking amazing. It
feels so good. But to get there,
you need to get through the first 30
minutes or however long of not enjoying it
or fucking Jujitsu. And I was taking
Jujitsu with Eddie Bravo, man,
that wasn't my mind was everywhere.
And like I know if I just had the
ability to focus on that for a year,
then that would have
radically transformed my life.
So that's why I say I wish that I could
figure out a way to make my mind become
immersed in anything that I want it to
instead of what it wanted to get immersed
in it. You still can,
not only can you still
do it, you, you,
what you described is the very difficult
aspects of things that you really enjoy.
It's a,
a subset or a,
another aspect of how you like find
what you enjoy and make what you enjoy
better. And that that involves doing
things that you don't enjoy at all.
It involves work.
And that's the weird sort of thing that
happens to kids when they learn a sport
or they learn a martial art or you know,
you,
you try out for the wrestling team
or something when you realize like,
I love wrestling,
but to get really good at wrestling,
you gotta go through wrestling
practice and that's a mother fucker.
And that's like this thing that
you learned in life. But you know,
when you're dealing with something
that you want to describe as attention
deficit disorder, that I don't think that
applies to that. I think all that is,
is a conditioning of discipline and a
recognition that discipline is like a mode
that you can put your mind
into and that you can achieve.
And it's also one of
those things where if you,
you have a characteristic that
you cultivate on a regular basis,
then it becomes a part of who you
are. If you get used to, uh, an act,
do you get used to have it?
All you have to do is do something for
90 days and that will become who you are.
You say, I'm going to take yoga every
day for 90 days. It seems impossible.
People had been doing it for years.
You can do it.
Just get up every morning at eight
o'clock whenever the fuck the class is and
take it for 90 days.
You will be a fucking Yogi
by the end of those 90 days.
That will be who you are, right? But
how many people ever actually do that?
That's the,
the discipline that that life requires.
And that's one of the lessons that
you learn once you apply yourself to
something. You learn how to
develop your human potential.
And one of the ways of developing
is a force yourself into and through
situations. But you're, you still
love the things that you love,
like video games,
like doing standup comedy,
things that don't require
the discipline at all.
You still pursue them and
have this passion for them.
It's just there's other stuff
too that's not on the surface.
You just have to work to get to it.
Got To get good at Jujitsu.
Fucking sucked when I
first started doing it,
but I knew that these guys were way
better than me and they were an immortal.
There were just people who practice more,
right? So in getting killed, I realized,
Ooh, if I just keep doing this, I can
eventually do that to someone else.
And when I first started playing quake,
same thing. I was getting crushed.
I would go online and spin around in
circles and dude would shoot rockets into
my face.
It was a terrible feeling.
And then I've learned how to
get really good at it because
I know, yeah, same was star craft.
Man tries starting that shit off, man.
You'll get your ass handed to
you. I still do. By the way,
everybody starcraft people out there,
I should make this very
important announcement.
This Friday at 1:00 PM I
will be a live streaming,
a match between me and Pendleton ward,
the creator of adventure time.
It was a play.
Starcraft kicked my ass
the last time we played.
We're having a rematch and it's being
cast by our tosas and Jeff Robinson who
are these like professional starcraft
casters and there's a caster.
What does that mean?
It's like what you do for the UFC,
but they do it for Starrco,
a broadcast, a broadcast.
So when you're playing starcraft,
they will do commentary on your strategy.
And me and Pendleton suck so bad.
So it'd be like you casting a UFC with,
with like me to go in Ra fighting.
Yeah, it'd be, yeah. It's like just,
we're not good at all,
but it's cool to get these two like
super professional casters to do it.
So that's at 1:00 PM Pacific Time.
I think it's going to be on twitch TV,
but I'll tweet about it.
For those of you who like star craft,
you can watch us flail.
Don't get an as eating, drinking the
mountain dew and eating no Doritos.
He's slowly,
I could imagine a cat thing.
I think that game is like one of those.
I think starcraft,
like you have to be on the ball all
the time. Correct me if I'm wrong.
You have to be the whole time. You
can't be like eating chips, right? No,
you can't eat fucking chips if you're,
if you're going to play a real game of,
sorry, you got to eat your cashews and
drink your coke and then he start playing.
You might be able to take some swigs of
water and the first four minutes or so
when you're building up your
army and your little circle,
things are just beginning to grow,
but you got ten six
basically. It's all time, man.
I'm not going to get an a starcraft.
I was with Dunkin in Utah.
We had a long drive to and from location.
It was like two hours from the airport
and we got into a starcraft conversation
and the passion in his voice,
when he describes
starcraft, it's like, man,
if you put that much effort into
anything else in your life, it becomes,
this is a real problem is that those
things don't pay off. You know,
they don't give you anything back.
No, I get really awesome at them,
but then at the end of the
day you don't have a car.
You don't have a house to show that
you're the best tennis player. No Man.
Pete Sampras like that guy has a
giant ass house. But like you know,
if you become like the motherfucker
had starcraft, how much can you make?
What are the best pro star
craft guys make $40 dude,
I have no that.
I think they make real money.
I know they can make you can make
real money. I think I'm wrong.
If you go to team liquid,
I,
I've saw somewhere there was a listing
of like how much like in fact when the
Pete,
when they,
when players start playing in
tournaments as part of their credits,
they will show the amount of money that
they've won over the course of their
career play. Wow. So you could see
how much money these people want,
but it's look professional.
Starcraft as a young man's game.
This is for somebody who's neurology
hasn't been frazzled by countless hits of
LSD and nitrous oxide.
It's like you've got to have like quick,
quick fucking what's called APM,
which is actions per minute.
Will they love this stuff?
By the way,
Alpha brain would definitely go over well
with some of these people who play the
game. I play the game just
for just for fun. I mean it's,
but I do recognize the time suck that
it is an inevitably when I'm playing,
I'll look at my watch and think,
why were you not writing
for the last two hours?
We just been running purple things
all over a screen for two hours.
Doesn't do anything for you. It
gets you, it does do something for,
I shouldn't say that because it has been
proven that it has a positive effect on
cognitive function. Okay.
It strengthens your, uh,
strengthens your decision
making abilities. Yeah.
And it makes your brain fire at
a rapid pace. They, for real,
they've figured this out with video games,
right?
That you're dealing with intense series
of things going on and you're managing
them and it's like an
exercise for your mind.
I just think it's a drug and I think that
it's like some drugs have benefits and
I think that it's a digital drug
and I think that when you're,
when you're playing so that,
you know,
when I'm playing a video
game for a long time, uh,
for a really long time, like if it's,
when I was addicted to world of Warcraft,
which I'd, I'm not anymore,
I don't play anymore.
But when I was due to
the world of Warcraft,
which was a true video game addiction,
and I think about spending a couple
of days playing that game is the main
activity in my day.
I don't really see much of a difference
in physical activity between me and
somebody who just got on the spike
and shot some heroin into his veins.
You know, I, he's going to be sitting
on the couch nodding in and out.
I'm going to be sitting on my chair
focused on a fantasy world and clicking
buttons. But our caloric, we're
not burning a lot of calories.
We're just kind of sitting in
a, in other words, if that team,
if my monitor was turned off and I was
just sitting there doing the same thing,
I might as well be,
it's like heroin,
except that I don't have a chemical
inside of me. So it's a drug,
it's a fucking drug.
And when the rift comes out,
when these new oculus rift, yeah,
man, when that shit comes out,
people are going to have to accept the
fact that we found another way to get
high.
That's as easy as addictive and
potentially life destroying is any other
hardcore narc.
Well, you keep hearing about these people
that abandon their babies because they,
uh, they've been playing a video game
and they let their kids starve to death.
You hear about that shit all the time.
It's happened several times. And you know,
these, these video games are only
getting more and more powerful.
So their impact,
what you're getting now is way stronger
than anybody ever got from monopoly and
Pong. You know? And then when Pong
became, you know, the PAC man,
and then when pac man became, when you're
dealing with now something that's way,
way, way, way, way more powerful.
And the question comes up is,
are we really designed to handle
that kind of stimulation? Right?
Our brains are set up for a whole series
of rewards that we get for finding
food. You find a rabbit, you shoot it,
then you get to eat. You know, there's
that thrill of catching it and eating it.
Well,
it said of rabbits,
you're doing swords or whatever the fuck
you're doing and you're serving your
deserves. You're sending your troops over
this three d mountain range. You know,
you're setting a trap.
On the other end and they retreat so you
can attack from the back end as well.
Yeah, it'd be evil, evil to
touch it. I don't want to
fuck with you. I love it man.
That's exactly what you just described
as a great strategy and that's part of
the fun of the game is like you
start learning new strategies.
There's cheese strategies
is what they're called,
which is like leave out a trout when
you attack within the first six minutes
it's like, oh or four minutes. There's
lane, it's lame and cheese is lame.
So like Ah, there's, there's
like some like you can,
instead of spending your
time building a giant army,
if within the first five minutes you
can build a very small army and get that
into your enemies base,
taking them by surprise and they
haven't built up any defense,
then you can sometimes defeat your enemy
within the first five minutes of the
game because they weren't
prepared for what's called a rush.
And that's called a cheese attack and
it pisses people off and it's so fun to
Piss people off when you're playing.
Cause then they'll chat to you
like you fucking new piece of shit.
What are you doing?
Cause they get really mad cause
it's lame cause it's just a lie.
Is it lame though? It seems like it's
an option. Well it's lame because it's,
it's it and I used to not,
I used to think,
I used to think like you think and because
I would love to do cheese attacks and
I thought it was funny but
you don't do it anymore.
You want to be taken seriously.
I don't want to be taking seriously.
I enjoy the game more
when I have bigger armies.
It's more fun when you like have to
deal with more variables and you let the
thing expand to like the,
the game is divided into phases.
So it's like mid game and game and the
beginning of the game and each of these
phases,
there's different strategies that you
employ according to what your enemies
doing. It's kind of boring
looking though, you know,
I mean I won't argue with that. A little
dudes are like, there are no big deal.
They're not very distinctive.
I like how they explode when you
shoot out him and still back to that.
What was that?
So look what we have here is I can't,
I can't see very well, it appears that we
have Taryn, these are Terrans attacking.
I can't tell what those fucking,
they turn into like little red puddles,
the explode when you shoot at some odd
Dunkin Zombie Mod. Oh, it's a Zombie.
Oh Wow. Starcraft Zombie mode. That looks
fun. So that's Terrans attacking zombies.
There are zombies that
are actually in the game,
but I've never seen those zombies before.
I wish it was um,
more first person.
I wish you have the opportunity to go
first person and then above just for the
visual enjoyment of it kind of cooler.
Really cool.
I keep praying that blizzard releases
some version of it where each member of
the armies can be somebody
else playing like halo styles.
So each of the armies are
like each individual troop
is being controlled by some
other players somewhere else. Oh Wow.
Fucking awesome. That be crazy. So you,
you literally would be an army of people.
How many people would you get
it into a game then? Well, you,
you can only get a maximum of 200 units,
so or,
or 200.
Not 200 units,
but it's like 200 supply is what
it's called because for every, uh,
every unit requires like for uh,
the Zerg to create units. You,
you'll Max out your unit.
So you start off,
you can only have 10 units on the board
and then you have to build a thing
called an overlord.
And for each overlord you get an,
you can build another five units.
So you could have a potentially
200 people as individuals.
200 different individuals logged into
a server. Well it wouldn't be at 200,
but it would be like,
you could have like 130 or
150 or something because a
certain units and anyway,
it's like it would be fucking wild.
It would be of 150 people
online representing a team.
I mean is that what's going
to happen with oculus rifts?
That seems like that would
be totally possible, I think.
I think that is going to happen with
Oculus rift and I think that, uh,
how many people are going to die
having heart attacks play on that,
playing that and probably not many,
but oculus rift having sex.
But what about the running with the
fucking running on the fucking Omni
Directional treadmills? Yeah, on the
Omni. Yeah. You're, no, you're right.
I mean I think that's going to be one of
the problems that we see is people are
going to get sick and people are
going to like go into cardiac arrest.
People are going to have
the most amazing legs ever.
People are going to be ripped,
but they're getting there.
People are going to be using,
this is something that uh,
Silva was talking about and he had a
word for like the mixture of certain
psychedelics and video games. Silva who?
Jason Silva, Jason Silva, he had this,
uh, he was talking about some kind of
mix of psychedelics and video games.
So it's like not only are you
going to be putting the rift on,
but you're going to be taking
some synthetic drug that
helps you merge into the
video game more so that you can merge
into it more. You get deeper into it.
Maybe it'll just be marijuana bath salts,
but you're going to smack that fucking
riffed on man and I haven't seen much
mention of of porn yet with the
Oculus riff, but come on man.
Think about first person porn.
They film the first porn
with the Google glass. Yeah,
some guy film porn with Google
glass. There you go, man.
I don't think Jo would like starcraft.
I think you'd be more like like
a battlefield for battlefield.
His battlefield where there's
tons of people playing out.
Well that's way better balance.
You're in that direct.
You're in three d like this
so you can get in planes,
you can get in tanks [inaudible] me.
This to me speaks to me as like an
individual, like as a human being,
experiencing life.
Like I know I'm just in a video game,
but you're running around with a machine
gun. You're flying around in a plane,
it's like you're seeing it from the
point of view of an actual player when
you're looking at it above.
I'm sure it's really cool,
but it lacks that feeling
like it's actually happening.
It's apples and oranges.
It's, it's chess versus quake itself,
a whole different thing. You're,
you're controlling, you know, it's
multitasking to the nth degree.
Makes them with planning and
mixed them with strategy,
with these kinds of first person shooters.
You're dealing with a whole different
type of gameplay and there those are
fucking fun, man. Let me,
I was just telling Brian,
I can wait for the new grand theft auto.
Yeah.
Wow. That looks amazing. And that's not
even on the new generation of consoles,
man. That's just a, that's
a, uh, that's on the,
we'll have access to that in a few
months and it looks so fun and I,
there's like a giant
forest in it I've heard.
And there's rumors that there's a big
foot that lives in the floor. Yeah.
That's awesome. I know, man. I can't
wait. Did you ever play quake, uh,
like a dual? Did you ever
do doubles with quake? Yeah,
duals are fascinating because they got
it down to when they know when weapons
would respond. So the whole key
to a duel was controlling the map.
You had to know where
the rocket launcher is.
You got to get to the guy before
the rocket launcher respond.
You had to make sure that
he never got a good weapon.
So all you have is like a
little blaster when you spawn.
And then if somebody kills you and
they're all armored up and they're filled
with weapons,
they can fuck you up.
And the key is like you got to figure
out a way to kill that guy while he's all
armored up.
It's very,
very difficult and it becomes like this
massive dual to get to various strong
spots on the map. Where's the armor?
Where's the the rail gun? Where's this?
And where's that?
It's so fun. And it's so funny,
the way to fun. Unfortunately, I,
I'd actually deleted my fucking star
craft so funny two nights ago to lead and
stark.
So many times I tried again.
I deleted starcraft and then
Pendleton texted me and he's like, uh,
w w w I want to come over on Friday
and kick your ass. It starcraft again.
And then it's like, oh fuck you man,
we'll play. Because I played Pendleton.
I didn't know that he knew how to play.
Oh,
I got really cocky and was like
being lazy and fucking around.
And then he likes stomped my ass.
He like crushed me and them
in the most horrible way.
So I wasn't prepared for that. I
thought he was like, just, just a,
just started playing. And you know what
I think he had, that's a pathetic thing.
That's how bad I suck. It started
just started playing and he got back.
He's just really a really, really smart
guy. I mean, have you seen adventure time?
Yeah, it's genius. So when you do it, um,
it's possible for someone to just
learn like right away. No, not me. I,
I'm,
I've been playing now for like,
you can learn the basics
pretty few years and I just,
I'm still on the silver league.
The silver league.
I just got out of the bronze league,
which is the lowest league.
It's just such a Dork. I gotta pee.
I'll be right back. All right, sorry.
Hey everybody.
Hi.
I had a pizza, but I've been
holding it in, but that's cool.
You go and then we'll go.
Have you seen this, um,
this new campaign about pornography?
They,
somebody sent it to me on Twitter
at pornography is the new drug.
Like this is the new drug and that,
and it's like fight, fight or blog.
Like they're fighting pornography.
It's like fight or blog and fighter.
It's very odd. It's a w what are,
what are they saying? Well, you know,
they're essentially saying things that
people have always said about pornography,
that people get addicted to, that it can
affect your relationships. And yet, Ken,
with some people, but it's another one
of those things. It's just like TV,
booze, cigarettes, any it fill in the
blank, right? It's like, yeah, yeah.
You could just jerk off all day.
And sometimes that happens to all
of us for like a week, you know,
especially when you're single,
you know when you were single,
like you could easily when you're live.
But when I lived by
myself and I was single,
I can easily have jerked off twice
a day for like a weekend in a row.
Yeah.
The other day I,
I I masturbated and then like I would
like two minutes later I was like, oh,
I'm in masturbating. I'm like,
wait, I still have comm on my hands.
Like I wasn't even like, like no time
had passed. I was only a few minutes.
Yeah. People are weird. The
weirdest fuck. And Yeah,
when you get something like pornography
where you could just watch people
fucking get stimulated for short,
you can get addicted to that.
But does that mean that
because you get addicted to it,
it shouldn't be available to people
that enjoy it? Does that mean, you know,
does that mean that just because you think
it dehumanizes people and objectifies
people that everyone looks at it that way?
Is that it definitely is changing
that the kids nowadays, Oh yeah.
Like these girls, like, you know,
I forget who, I think it was,
Sarah Tiana has a bit about
it where, where, you know,
like the girls are growing
up nowadays things,
it's normal to get cummed on their
face. So, you know what I mean?
Like that's what you're supposed
to do when you have sex, you know,
or you're supposed to have a fist
in your ass once in a while and,
and all the cause the porn so
shocking and crazy and he's like in,
they're watching it at such
a young age that, you know,
usually back in the day you used
to look at a playboy Django,
the hacker has nice boobs.
You're not seeing like crazy full on
triple x porn back then and people are
seeing it on the phone and they're
in nursing. It's at a young age.
Yeah. It's almost like you can't
stop it. Yeah. And you know,
the other thing is how about grooming,
grooming,
the grooming, the pubic hair. Oh yeah.
Porn one that porn won that battle.
Okay. Everybody does it now.
It's very rare that girls let their whole
box get get crazy and France is going
extinct actually because of that.
That's, yeah. That's awesome.
I'm going to pee now. Feel free to
talk shit about me while I'm gone.
Isn't that amazing that crabs are
going extinct? Yeah, that's weird.
They're like the indigenous people and
the rain forest that are getting wiped
out. To think that we had something that
you know is going to be extinct one day.
Disney should do a cartoon about like a
tribe of crabs living in the pubic hair
or someone who's on the verge of shaving
their her pussy and they've got to like
convince her not to do it.
Save it,
do I? I love it, man.
I had this girl recently that had a bush
and I forgot how nice it was to have a
bush.
You can just a little teeny Bush.
I get it.
I mean I,
if a girl wants to shave her pussy
because it makes her feel better,
I think it's good, but it's not
something I really, I liked that much.
I like it when there's
some hair down there.
I always just feel weird when they've,
they've decided to take
that leap because I mean if,
if it makes them more comfortable,
it makes sense.
But if they're trying to appeal to
some notion that that's what guys want,
I think that could be a little
off base. You know? I don't,
I don't know that that's exactly the,
the thing that guys fantasize
about, man, just a nice shave pussy,
right. I, I've never gotten it. I've
never, that's never been a thing that,
it just made me feel like, wow, you're
really committing to, to fucking right.
I just recently started shaving my balls
because Joe says that he shaves his
balls and he'd be like,
you know what?
I've never really just like shaved him
completely bald and so I did and it's so
much nicer.
When do you use just a razor?
Put some soap on it or some shaving cream
and I could Gillette sensor once I was
trimming my pubes and I
sliced a piece of my like Oh,
skin with the scissors.
It was really sad because like I was
about to go on a date and I'm like,
I got to trim this Bush. And I ended
up like cutting a piece of my skin off.
So it's like now if we end up having sex,
she's gonna think I have some kind of
soul. Never going to believe you either.
I can't. Like I was trimming my cubes for
you. I was so excited that I cut myself.
I caught my dick and a
zipper once more than once,
but once in a way that
it left like a mark,
like a little herpes mark or something.
So painful. Yeah. Well, yeah,
you got to wear underwear,
you know? Yeah. You got it.
One time I caught it with underwear
and it was not that bad. I've,
I've caught my dick so
many times and a zipper.
I can't even imagine
if I had a countertop,
I'd be so sad and I'll fucking stupid.
I am.
It's more than a dozen over my whole life,
but one time it was bleeding.
That's how Jay Dow Chase Algaes.
Yeah, I could button flight. Nowadays,
I hate zippers, but I'm flies a
good move. I got a problem, man. I,
I need to figure out better pants.
I need to start wearing pants that are
too big and then like get a belt that
ties it down because when,
when pants fit my waist,
they don't fit my troll like thighs.
Well you just, you know, I mean,
do you get straight leg?
Do you get I get bought baggy
ones then they're not baggy.
They have to be like skateboarder
baggy to be baggy on me.
Like regular Levi five oh ones. Good
fucking luck. Those I can't put those on.
I can't even get those. I
get those halfway up. My
fine. They're stuck. I can't,
I can't wear them. Like that's the regular
jeans that guys are supposed to wear.
I can't wear those. I guess. Can't you
buy him big and just go to a tailor?
I think I'm going to have
to buy him the right length,
but a wider waste just to
see if they make the legs.
They must make your legs bigger than they
figure you're a fat fuck. Yeah. This, uh,
I got a,
I got a real problem with that though
because on TV I look like I'm wearing
girls jeans because my jeans,
like they're tight on the top.
Like I'm wearing skinny jeans.
You can see my pack.
It was just all bundled
in there and talked.
There's this app called Tinder.
Have you heard of the rent?
No. No, I haven't heard of it. It's
Tinder. Tinder is this thing where it,
what it does,
it's based on location and it will uh,
it will pull up a girl's
photo and it will say like,
this girl is like block from
you. And he say like, uh,
like POW or like us thumbs up or thumbs
down and you can like look through their
photos and everything like that.
But, uh, my friend Benji Afflalo,
he found this like secret.
So what we do is we just sit there as
fast as we can and except, except, except,
except don't even look at the foot cause
you're like going through like millions
of them and if they like you back,
uh, it brings up a chat room.
And this guy I know, he says that he's
gone for the last six months. He's uh,
gone on like 30 dates and
about 90% of them he's fucked.
Yes man. I guys, that guy's
on a rampage. Fuck me.
And addicted to pornography.
That's what he's doing.
We were talking to when you went to p
about there's a some new campaign called
about pornography being the new
drug and uh, I don't disagree,
but I don't agree that you should stop it.
I don't agree that you should
tell people they can't do it.
I don't agree that you can tell
people they shouldn't watch it.
I feel like it's like everything else,
just like booze, just like cigarettes,
just like coffee. You can, you can
overdose on star Trek, starcraft.
You can overdose and everything and
you could overdose on porn or a regular
person. I th I believe it's
possible to watch, to jerk off,
watch a little bit of porn
and then go about your day.
I know people that do that.
I just know age,
these fucking fundamentalist
creeps would get there.
God Damn Morality and ethics and
fear dynamics out of our orgasms.
I don't think that this is a
fundamentalist organization. I don't,
I sound from what I looked
maybe from what I looked though,
it didn't reference religion at all.
It seemed to be that was just there.
You know, it was just a, uh, uh,
an organization that thinks
that pornography itself
is detrimental to society
and to relationships. And I could see
how they would say that, but I say no.
I say though,
the behaviors of people that are addicted,
those are the things that are detrimental
to societies and those behaviors can
manifest themselves in porn. They can
also manifest themselves in gambling.
They can manifest itself in a
lot of different crazy things.
People are fucking nuts.
And the regular day to day job of no risk,
no reward,
that that pattern of life is not
fucking rewarding. And because of that,
people have these big,
they'd go on these nutty Chase's often
to the woods of craziness and they'll,
they'll bet their entire house
on a fucking hand of cards.
They'll still do nutty shit.
That man,
it's not always because of a mundane jobs,
but there's a part of us, whatever
it is, whatever is the cause of it.
The point is there's a part of human
beings that will just get obsessed with
something and get crazy with something
and just fucking along with it and then
go, oh Jesus, what did I do? And it
could be that with pornography I'm sure.
But it could be that with almost anything.
And if you looked at the amount of
people that watch pornography and aren't
crazy and don't objectify women because
of it and aren't mean to people because
of it and don't hate and
don't want to rape and kill,
I would have to assume
that that's much larger.
And there's also studies that show that
people that are exposed to whether it's
extreme like rough sex or,
or,
or different types of sex are
different, different, you know,
different sexual acts that it can ease
their desire to perform those acts that
it can actually like, especially
like things like, like rough sex.
Like there's some people that have like
fantasies about that they can watch it
in a porn and never want to hit somebody.
Right.
And they think that it can act as,
you know,
it can have some sort of
an alleviating effect.
And I don't know if these
studies are biased. I don't
know if you know, they were,
they went into it trying to
prove something and if it's
been rejected by science,
but I know the argument is kind of strange
that it has that sort of alleviating
effect that has that sort of a release
mechanism effect like violent movies.
A lot of people feel the same way.
I find it an incredibly strange that
we have no problem with violent movies.
There's very little blow
back to these Batman movies.
Zombie movies are all
these different movies,
but yet if there was that same type
of extreme sexuality in a film,
we would lose our fucking minds.
Yeah.
But it is an extreme
violence just as disturbing,
if not more disturbing
than extreme sexuality.
Well, isn't it funny that the two even
get put in the same goddamn category?
Right.
Did there even compared like one,
you have like just
pleasure seeking people,
trying to reach a temporary
utopian states, uh,
by coming on the other,
you have people actively killing each
other and yet somehow people even bring
those two together. It's like talking
about dragons versus butterflies,
like one just supposed to be fun, you
know, and I think that's one of the,
that that's one of the problems with this
repressed sexual culture that we live
in is that what ends up
happening is people watch
porn and what they're seeing a
lot of times is the result of
sexual repression. You know,
when you get that creepy narrator,
I'm sure we've talked about this before,
but that guy who were like ruins the porn.
You know what I'm talking about?
The creepy narrator like, yes, Ooh, what
do we have here? A little dirty girl.
You dirty, you dirty, you want to suck.
He's known as the worst was
when the camera man does it.
The girls having sex with the guy
and the camera has gone, Oh yeah,
you want to suck his cock it all
the way down. You're like, Hey,
what's going on here?
Who's that creep at the camera?
You know that fucking Weirdo.
So fucking weird man. And
it's like, Eh, the, the, the,
that porn down, you know that thing?
What is that? Where suddenly no, yeah,
this is what we're doing.
And sometimes it's the girl too.
Sometimes girls can be like, oh yeah,
fucking baby. Oh yeah. And you're
like, Hey Jesus, what's going on here?
That thing. So all the screaming. Yeah.
That thing, that thing is so weird.
And that is just a result I
think of sexual repression. Okay.
I don't know about that. I think is to
some guys, that's what they like to hear.
Some guys want to hear that girl being
all loud and obnoxious. Fuck my ass baby.
And then some guys also want to hear the
guy, you know, I think we saw the style.
So everyone's wildly, everyone's
got their own style. The point is,
how weird are we were extreme violence
is the expendables. It's everywhere
now. They shoot someone that had
their fucking brain explodes.
That's someone's baby.
That guy just shot someone's
baby that grew up in the head.
And His fucking skull exploded and we
accepted cause he's the bad guy. Right.
You know,
and w w w why is that acceptable?
Why is that not just acceptable
but barely criticized?
Well it's because a long time ago
some really fucked up dudes started
controlling everything and it's been
going on and on like that for a very long
time.
And we're the,
we're the descendants of super sexually
repressed fundamentalist religious
fanatics who came over here to start
Utopian societies and is part of their
understanding of things.
Decided that they were going to
lock that pussy underneath a Bible.
And that's what where we're at today.
She's true, isn't it? That is what it is,
isn't it? Yes. It's just a, it's just a,
a really beautiful Massey act
that's kind of embarrassing,
but it's just ultimately fun and we've
managed to turn it into a Goddamn
multiside h p Lovecraft monster that
you're not supposed to talk about.
Certainly never show it to your kids.
Never want your kids to see sex ever.
That's the worst thing. It's like
the most we, it's just fucked up.
It's like Nancy Grace Shit man. It's
taking off. Did you hear about that? Yeah.
Some guy was trying to kill Nancy grace.
Yeah, with once at knives and stuff.
What was he on his way to her house or
something? I don't know. You Know Jamie?
Yeah. Jamie. Well Poor Nancy
grace. Are you all doing,
are you allowed in bed? Am I loud in
bed? Yeah. Do you make noises there?
You the fuck are you, I don't want
to know. It takes a little secret.
I very, uh, very wildly
like in all things.
I do like to talk so that I can hear you.
It depends on what kind of
sex is happening. What kind
of ball gag he's gotten.
His mouth.
It depends on outside.
Did you guys see that? And Yoko Ono
thing speaking a ball gag. I've seen that
new thing that she did. The, the, the
sing, the cover of the Adele Song.
I saw that. That's kind
of old. I've seen that.
How old is it? A Dell has only been
around for a couple of years. I mean,
I saw it like a year ago. 2012.
Yeah. Pull it. Pull it up.
Because this bears repeating for the
fix for folks who haven't seen this in a
home that's a kitty. She
does this thing. I Dunno.
I mean it's almost like now
she's like heard the criticism.
So she's just taken it to the
next level and making it a joke.
And so Yoko Ono is at
this art gallery and uh,
she pulls up this microphone.
It's really,
she's like really strange.
Someone like you as the song and uh,
she's dressed like real weird and
people still sort of give her attention
because she was John Lennon's wife
and John Lennon was, you know,
a motherfucker in his time.
So she gets up to this microphone.
So weird.
No,
and I'm sure most of the
people in the crowd were like,
what the fuck John Lennon,
what did you do to us?
Isn't it
kind of making fun of a doubt?
I don't know. I think she be,
cause that's kind of like,
maybe that's her interpretation
of modern music or something.
Like she's like making fun of what
she considers to be the empty,
uh,
emptiness.
Sir. The book. And you're
looking into it too far, pal.
This is why I say not because she
never did anything good before that.
It's not like she did something that
was like really cool and interesting and
then people really got into it and
then she's doing this as a parody. No,
this is what she's always done that,
that thing
there,
that law.
She's always done that like bill burr
had this whole Clarius bit about Chuck
Berry and John Lennon
doing a solo together.
They're a duo rather and there they're
singing this song and you know John
Lennon's they're singing and
Yoko ono is like playing the,
the fucking tambourine,
the background and she just
pulls up a microphone and goals.
Nah,
like she,
she makes this crazy noise and like,
and you could see the look on
Chuck Berry's face. Like they've,
whoever made the video of the
bill birthing did an awesome job.
He is it mischief maker? Did he make it?
No. Some other dude, whoever made it,
they froze frame. Right. When Chuck Berry
had this crazy looking as I was like,
yeah,
what the fuck the bitches do, man. I've
noticed that there's people like that.
He will attach themselves
to things and ruin it.
Like there's always a lot of times
you'll find yourself around someone who's
just going to squawk out some
bullshit and ruin everything. Yeah,
I would love to see that Brian.
Yeah, it's yet to see the
bill version of it. Okay.
No, but anyway, she's up to
playing the bongos. Right.
So John Lennon,
Chuck Berry,
two of the greatest of all time
harmonizing singing this hit from the 1950
[inaudible].
That's what this moment is about.
And Yoko in the middle of it can't
handle that. She's not getting any shine.
She takes the fucking
microphone out of the stands,
starts playing the Bongo and as
they're singing, you know, go,
go Johnny go whatever. She picks up
the mic and I swear to God goes, yeah,
some fucking crazy shit.
Fucking open as wide as
they are in that fucking,
what did he do?
What is it
bout the some dudes like a John Lennon
type guide that seems by all accounts to
be like one of the coolest people that's
ever lived. This brilliant artist,
these amazing songs,
this great way of looking at life.
And then he has this really weird way
Asian fetish man back then it wasn't
that common to have an Asian girlfriend.
Right.
I think it was also who she was.
I think some women will provide,
they will provide like a guidance thing
to some guys like Ozzy Osborne's wife,
obviously a very strong woman,
very opinionated,
successful business woman and she takes
care of one of the craziest guys in rock
and roll.
That's why that show was so interesting
because you've got this guy that's like
eating pigeons heads on stage.
He's a fucking animal.
He's done every drug known to man. He
goes on stage and kids go fucking crazy.
It's fucking awesome.
He represents the ANC asked
of every fucked up kid.
He's God Damn Ozzy Osborne,
you know,
and he's singing crazy train
and everybody's going nuts.
And then he's got this wife who's
like on the ball taking care of shit,
putting things in line,
managing his career, make
sure he gets paid. Let's with,
we're going to do a reality
show, honey, you know,
and all of a sudden a whole reality
check and he's running around.
He's barely talk,
he's going to fucking reality show his
wife and his kids are getting all the
attention because I mean, well not all
the attention, but I mean he's, he's,
it's almost impossible to understand them,
but they find this and hit,
in his case, it was a positive, you know,
he found this woman who was like really
on the ball, but in John Lennon's case,
not, he just found this woman who
just said, come here, hold my hand,
I'll take this, I got this. And
she just, I've seen it happen.
I've seen it happen with comics.
Have you ever met a comic and a,
they have a girlfriend that
sort of running the show?
Kristina Brzezinski Thompson girls,
Polaris. That's, that's a bad one.
But I had a friend back in the
day, he, sadly, he's passed. Um,
but he had a girlfriend and
his girlfriend was, you know,
sort of like his manager type situation.
Just running the show. Like, you know,
deciding what he does, what he
doesn't do and they get, you know,
they get linked up together and it gets,
it gets weird.
It's like they become a package deal.
Like every time you're around Mike,
you're also around sending
like, oh Jesus, here we go.
Or they'll start sharing emails.
Yes. Oh, that's a big one.
That's a big one. Where they have
the same email account. Yeah.
He may even the wife have the same
meal. Okay. Dude, I'm not trying,
I don't know your wife. We're not friends.
Okay. I'm trying to send you an email.
Do you have your own email so we can
talk shit and I can maybe send you a porn
link and not, and not have to
deal with your wife going, hey,
that's a shared email account and an
appreciate you sending him all your
bullshit. Every time you call they're on
fucking speaker. Oh, that's bad. Yeah,
that's bad.
Or how about when the woman answers the
phone and it's his cell phone? Yeah.
You know, you're like, hello. I thought
I was calling Mike. Oh, who is this?
Is Mike there? Yeah. Who is this
please? Like, oh Jesus. Like you know,
not even famous people. Uh, this is Cho.
Can I talk to, and then you like, dude,
why is your girlfriend answer your
phone? Oh Hey, I don't care. You know,
it's no big deal.
It's just laying around like that person
is like controlling your environment.
So weird. Isn't it so
weird? So it's weird.
It's just as weird if a guy does it.
If the girl's phone's ringing the cruiser.
Hello, Debbie. Oh yeah,
I'll get her old army.
I ate Joe. I hate that.
Sloan you to talk to Debbie.
So creepy man.
When people try to control each other
like that, it's so spooky, isn't it?
It is spooky. It's dangerous
too. It's tricky. It's dangerous.
You got to just know when someone really
likes you and if they don't like you
either find someone that does or
figuring out what's wrong with yourself.
If you don't,
you're going to get in that cycle of,
I'd like that girl that I dated that
went through my phone and it took
screenshots of every
single text I did the hook,
every photo that I had in there
and send it to herself. Like,
like pretty much spent four hours
while I was sleeping in bed,
just going through my phone and
making copies of everything.
Well that's obviously a person that
thought you were doing something different
than what you were doing. She just
decided that she had the right to do that.
You know, have the right to do
that to people. Don't, you know,
and that's one of the weirdest
things about, to become the NSA.
You don't have the right to go
through someone's phone. I mean,
if someone's lying to you, yeah, that
sucks. It sucks that someone lied to you,
but you know what sucks just as bad.
Are you going through their fucking phone?
That's, that's uh, I mean,
finding out that someone
betrayed you by betraying them,
nobody wins there. You
know, that's not a win.
And it's certainly not a win
if you're using it to, to fuck.
It's like people need to figure
out a way to just get along better.
I don't know what it is.
I don't know how,
how you eliminate the 50% plus divorce
rate that we have in this country.
I don't know how you get it so that
people can figure out how to not be that
person, not be the woman, not be the man.
Not me the problem, but fuck. It's so,
it's so hard to do. Yeah, you got to let
go, man. You just got to let go. I mean,
you got to let go. It's, if
somebody is going to leave you,
they're going to leave you.
Well,
it's not just that it's you gotta
let go while you're with them too.
That's what I mean.
I'm saying like going through,
by the time it gets to the point where
you're going through somebody emails to
see if they're cheating on you, that
fucking, that ship has left the port.
It's over.
Whether they're cheating on you or not.
You guys are so unconnected that
you don't know what they're doing.
Well,
you never know what someone's doing and
now you don't trust what they're doing.
Right.
You're still on connected.
Did you hear about that
guy that disappeared for 22
years or I think it was 19
years, something like that. Long ass
time. His family assumed he was dead.
They had five children.
They got a life insurance policy,
$800,000 and it turns out he was living
with his gay lover in Palm Springs.
Wow. Talking to you tweeting right now.
You're not really hearing I'm sculpting.
Joe. When he squeezed, it's called thing.
Played Out. What's wrong with this guy?
Like he was a deeply religious guy and
just couldn't deal with his sexuality.
It was just too crazy for him. He
couldn't handle it and then he went crazy.
He went on a vacation
and just never came home.
He just moved in with this gay guy and
just starts sucking cock and taking the
but and then just loved it.
Just like this is the place for me.
So much so that he abandoned his
children and now his children,
like they were eight at the time.
Now they're grown.
Like one of them was a grown woman and
she has children of her own and she's
like,
I would never do that to my kids.
Like he doesn't understand
like he left when I was eight.
That was devastating to lose your father
when you're eight just because you know
you can't come out of the closet.
So you go and you never come
back for like x amount of years,
1516 whatever the fuck years it was. And
then finally do come back and like, look,
I fucked up. Like wow,
people can do that too.
But that's one of those things you've
got to realize like we're crazy. We can,
that's, that's also in the wheel
house of human behavior. It is.
Ukie I mean that's the trick I think of
relationships. It's just you gotta be in,
you have all kinds of things.
You've got to be in the
moment with the relationships.
If you start holding onto the idea
that that shit's going to last forever,
you're, you'll start
going crazy. That, that,
that's never the case.
It's just never the case.
You have to appreciate the moments
that are good and then the moments that
aren't so good, you've got to trust that
things are going to get better. Yeah.
And you've got to have a support system.
You got to have some exercise in your
life to blow out the fucking bad hormones
can have a lot of shit going on.
And we're not told this.
You got to figure it out over stumbling
through your life, running in the wall.
This is the question I have for you.
It's something I've been thinking about.
Men in a relationship is a
great way to bring it up. Okay.
If you don't feel loving towards someone,
if you don't feel it,
and that quite often happens
in relationships where
you just not feeling it
right. How were you supposed to
act? In other words, you can't,
if you're not feeling it and you
start acting like you're feeling it,
aren't you being dishonest or
phony? Hmm. Well, you have to.
That's a really,
that's a giant general question and that's
the problem because it really depends
entirely on the moment.
It depends entirely on you that person.
The variables are so vast.
The variables of of people,
the variables of scenarios, the variables
of lifestyle, the variables of culture,
the veil variables of what part
of the world you're living in.
There's a lot of variables when you're
going to answer that question and it's
like, why do you know you're not loving
what that person who have fucked,
I don't know your situation and to find
out your situation would take a long
time.
I would have to have a definitely deeply
delve into each one of your individual
lives and they wake up in the morning,
you're a little hung over.
I'm not even talking about relationships.
You go to work, you feel like shit.
You don't feel kind, empathetic,
compassionate at all.
You don't want to listen to anybody.
Yap.
Okay.
Are you faking it? If you start
acting kind to the people around you,
what's better to follow that feeling and
just be kind of like closed off or to
try to act as though you're happy.
Are you care about the people around you?
Well that's a different
scenario and that scenario,
I feel like you have an obligation to be
kind to the people that are around you
as much as is humanly possible
without compromising your own sanity,
without,
you know,
getting to the point where someone's
taking advantage of you being kind and
they're just ruining your life and acting
like a shithead all time and you're
like, hey dickhead, how about
pay attention to yourself?
How about you not do that?
How about you not spew out every stupid
thought that comes out of your fucking
mouth that ruins everybody
else's conversation because
you're doing something
really selfish, right?
Sometimes you have to do that.
Sometimes you have to regulate.
But other than that,
like if you go into work hung over,
that's on you bitch. All right.
Be Nice to everybody and
you as a human being,
you should do it because you
want to do it. And if you think,
I don't want to do it, you're in
the wrong frame of mind, period.
And that's not a generalization.
And that type of a scenario,
what I thought you were talking about was
inside the confines of a relationship.
And if you don't feel loving to someone
inside the confines of a relationship,
well you know,
there's so many possible variables,
but I ultimately think if you're, if
you're a balanced person, if you're,
if you are at least in
the mode of balance,
like trying to attempt to achieve balance,
you should go with your instincts.
And if this is not the person for you,
this is not the person for you. Right.
You know?
Yeah, no, I'm in, I just was using
that cause we were talking about it.
I just mean in general,
you know, there's the
prescription, uh, you know,
you'll just be nice even if you
don't feel it. Yeah, you can be nice.
You can be nice. You mean you get
sometimes get upset, you know,
sometimes you know, just like, oh
look, I'm sorry man, I just fucking,
today's crazy with me. But you know,
unless they're doing something to you,
be nice. It's not their fault
that you're hung over some,
their fault that you're troubled.
It's not their fault, you know,
as long as they're not like
interfering with your ex,
as long as they're not being rude or
disrespectful to your own space. You know,
we have all been there before. Like if
you come to me and you're like, dude,
I'm sorry I'm just in a shitty mood,
but hey,
no worry about a man who loves
to talk. Just chill, relax.
Like that's one thing about guys to like
say if you and I were in a car. Okay.
And you like to a man, I just don't,
I really, I don't want to talk.
I just want to sit. I'll be like,
I get it. No worries. Just chill.
Like you can do that. But yeah. Well if,
if a guy and a girl are together
and the guy's like, look,
I just don't want to fucking talk. I just
like, you know, within 10 minutes like,
okay, what's wrong? You can tell
me what's wrong. What is it?
It's such a problem,
man.
It's such a problem cause cause
like I like to be quiet sometimes.
Like I like to just have moments of
quiet and stuff and it really is tough
because sometimes it feels like girls
translate that quiet into exactly what
you're saying.
And it's a real problem.
Well men and women are so
fucking radically different
as human beings with the
hormone levels, the, the,
the life experiences,
the goals and dreams and the
fact that men want to fuck women.
And the fact that women are
willing to let men fuck them.
It's like all of it is so bizarre.
There were so radically divided in like
who we are and then yet we love each
other and yet we're constantly around
each other. And if you're in a,
a relationship that you know is that
you really enjoy and is really serious,
you're around them all the time.
Like most of the day on a regular basis.
You know?
And it's strange.
It's a Greg Fitzsimmons is a fucking
great bit about it where he talks about
like if I had to choose to be with one
person on an island for the rest of my
life, he goes, if it was you or
my wife, I'd be like, sorry honey,
I'm going to live with Joe on an island.
It's like he goes,
cause we're going to have fun. He goes,
when was the last time you went to,
I'm going to have a great
conversation with my wife. He's like,
that doesn't fucking happen. He's
like, he goes, yeah, I love her. Yeah,
we have children together, but I'm
hanging out with my friend. He goes, yeah,
we're not going to get any
sex but so what? We'll just
go jerk off in the bushes.
Then we'll make each other laugh
or the rest of the day and,
and you know that's because we are,
we're we're men and we understand men.
And that's why when women get together
and they tell jokes about purses and
shoes and what a fucking 50 shades of
grey or whatever the fuck they're into,
whatever their, their, their
style of person is into, you know,
whether it's whatever,
feminist jokes, whatever,
they get together and they laugh at
the shit that they think is funny.
And if you were there, you'd
be like, Oh fucking Christ.
But for them it's so awesome.
They're laughing,
they're lol in and they're saying stupid
shit to each other that they like to
hear. Why? Because they don't have
estrogen or they don't have testosterone.
Rather they have estrogen, they have
ovaries, they don't have a penis,
they have a vagina, they have totally
different setup. It's a different animal.
It's a totally different thing.
So for you to try to become what
she wants you to be, that's madness.
And for you to want her to become
what you want her to be like,
that's madness too.
Like you got to figure out what each
other is and just sort of accept it.
And as soon as you don't do that,
you're fucked. You're fucked. It's,
you're just going to fucking hit
the rocks. It's not gonna last.
It's gonna fall apart.
You're closing your eyes and hitting the
gas and one day eventually going to hit
something. It's not gonna work.
All right. Yeah, it's true.
So when someone's going through your
fucking emails and checking your text
messages and sending all that
shit to themselves, that's not,
it's never going to work. It's never
going to work for all the raw what?
You don't know, he's crazy, right?
You don't know Brian red bands a freak
and you're not paying attention, right.
How are you not paying attention? Did
you not know this guy? I know this guy.
You know I don't have to
look at his phone. I know
him. You know, it's like you,
we were so radically different though
that that is a lesson that's so easily
said and so impossible to absorb.
And then it doesn't help that if
you tune into the view, you know,
and they're all going, oh no girl,
he needs to give you his phone.
You need to take that phone.
You need to be able to look at that
phone anytime of day, whatever you want,
you need to be able to do that.
Pornography is just as bad as cheating.
I've heard that. I've heard that there
was an argument that was on the, uh,
the fight porn website though a woman
was saying that porn was watching.
Porn is just as bad as cheating,
but just crazy talk, you know,
it's there. We just, we're just weird.
It's totally different at Muskrat's
in Unicode, he's dating a girl once,
a long time ago and I made the mistake
of leaving porn up on the computer and
leaving and like, she came in
and saw whatever porn website add
up in my apartment. I don't remember
why she's going into my apartment,
but I remember coming home, I guess I
told her to meet me there or something.
I don't have American coming home.
She's sitting on my bed and she's in
tears and she's like, is this who you are?
This is what you like.
You like jerking off to this shit.
I'm not good enough for you. It was
shocking because I, at that time I didn't
realize it. That was some women, wait,
I associated my four minutes or five
minutes of lubing up my hand and jerking
off to some random gay porn
clip is like something, um,
something offensive. Yeah. I didn't
cause it's such a small little,
it's such a small little thing.
That's what you failed to mention though.
It was gay porn. That's why
she was pissed off. Wow. Wow.
Yeah. I would, I date with a
girl whose mom is I older than,
or younger than me. Oh, Christ.
He's there any booze in here, man.
Can we get a drink? Yeah, I have
ice. Uh, no. Yeah. Was it was nine,
925. It's not going to start
until 10 o'clock. Um, we're
at the Ice House tonight,
folks.
If you have an a,
if you're in the neighborhood and you
haven't made plans for the evening,
hey dude, did you happen
to get ice? Did you show,
did you see that fucking Pacific rim?
Uh, no, I didn't. Did
you? Yeah, you did see it.
We were talking about it the other day.
Oh, ugh. Ugh, oh my fucking God, man.
So really add, it's visually really
cool, but the characters are,
I tweeted that in like it and caught a
lot of flack from really people who like
robots and Godzillas and
they're like Gluco. Have you
ever seen a Godzilla movie?
You expect that to have good
characters and it's like, come on you.
Just because it's got fantasy beings
in it doesn't mean it can't be good.
Right? There's a lot of fantasy beings
movies that are awesome. You know,
even simple ones like you
didn't like Avatar though.
Avatar I liked better than I liked.
I see. I made it through Avatar.
I didn't make it through Pacific rim.
I laughed really 40 minutes in.
Oh my God, I can't believe that
bored out of my fucking mind.
That's amazing. And this is a Benicio
del Toro or a not be so the Torah,
one of those things where he presents
it. I don't know if he did, if it was,
I'm not positive about that,
but he did the same thing with Mama where
it's like Guillermo del Toro presents.
Mama do you just like, it's attaches
a name to it. I mean, I would,
I would not go see Pacific rim.
I would go see that movie that's coming
out this Friday about the, the new, um,
what's his name? The guy or did grizzly
man. Oh yeah, yeah. Werner Herzog. Yeah.
He's putting out a movie
called the act of killing.
Yeah.
Oh, I heard about. Very
disturbing. I heard it's,
it's a disturbing and I heard
it's brilliant. Yeah. His
stuff is always brilliant.
So one thing that I didn't connect
with with him is that cave, uh, the,
the movie about the Cave Art.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Cave of forgotten dreams.
It didn't, for whatever reason, I didn't
really, I dunno. I didn't enjoy that.
That's a snoozer dude. That one. Yeah.
Knocks your ass out. Yeah. I don't know.
I don't know why everybody liked that
one. I was watching that one. I was like,
hmm. I don't, there's nothing there for
me. But um, I love the happy people.
I told you about that one life on the
taiga about all these people that live in
Siberia and their trappers and,
and fishermen.
And hunters and they're just so happy.
They're all like dancing and
hugging each other and you know,
they're living off the land and,
and teaching each other how to, uh,
how to survive this. It's really
a, it's an amazing movie. Yeah.
He's a genius man. Yeah.
He's a bad motherfucker.
And also I heard black fish is really good
too. What's blackfish? Black fishes a,
I think it's called black fish.
It's about seaworld and it's about the
way they kidnap orcas and bring them in
and how the work is like,
you know,
every once in a while the oracle will
like grab one by the arm or kill one of
them got killed. An orca killed one
of them, but you know, it's the,
these are super intelligent beings
that you're keeping in a swimming pool,
swimming pool basically.
And it's just torture and a hellish exists
stents for them and, yeah. And they're
like, what? Oh, I can't understand you.
I guess you're going to have to keep
doing tricks if you want fish. Yeah.
Do you want this fish? Okay.
You know what I want from you?
I want you to flip out of here.
I don't know what you're saying.
Do you want the fish? You
have to flip? Uh, yeah.
I know they sound of the dolphins can,
will they believe rather
than the dolphins have names,
names for each other? Yes.
Yeah. It's so cool and I'm
sure orcas do too. I bet. Yeah.
There they killed off ones though.
They call them non human people in India.
That's what they've started
calling them as non human people.
Yeah, they're, it's, it's really
obvious. They're smartest shit.
There's no way that they should
be in swimming pools. That's it.
So horrific. Did you see that
woman in front of the Dolphin?
A aquarium doing back flips for them and
they stopped to watch her and it's like
they're really into watching it.
They bought two of them are his
sort of sitting there watching.
One of them seems to be like grinning.
It seems like they're really smiling
like they think it's funny or weird.
Have you seen when they look
in the mirror, have you seen
those videos? Yeah. Yeah.
That's amazing. They like pose and like
they like they really are into them.
They're very aware of what they are.
Yeah,
and I think it's cool to
them to see themselves.
Like they don't get to see
that on the ocean ever.
So all of a sudden they have a mirror.
It's gotta be a weird thing to have
that sort of branch of development where
they are.
Cerebral cortex is very evolved.
They have this very complex language
dialects and so complex and so different
from ours that we don't understand it.
We are trying to pick out
patterns and bits and pieces,
but as far as anyone been
able to translate dolphin
until like a code that you
could read as English text, no one's
been able to do that. They can't do it,
but yet they understand what
you're saying when you say, hey,
you want a piece of fish, you want
to be some fish, do your flip.
And they'll do the flip. Like they know
what you're saying. They, they, they,
they can understand what you're saying
but we don't understand what they're
saying.
It's really kind of interesting.
It's fascinating, man. I think
a lot of what they're doing,
I saw some documentary on them.
I wish I remember what it was,
but it's how their languages,
a lot of it's movement too.
It's not just the sounds they're making,
but on top of it as the movements
that they're making with the sound.
And it's also a relational to the,
to,
it's like a more of a dance that
they're doing with, what do you call it,
a pack of dolphins. What do you call it? I
think as a pack. Yeah. I, it's like more,
it's, it's like they have more
of a unified consciousness
than human beings do.
They're more of one thing.
And so the communication is something
that's not as much based on school of
Dolphins, a school, a pod,
pod, pod, and you go, yeah,
a plurality of why
they move in very strange ways together
like that. That is kind of cool.
And they also, they, they're,
they're capable of using sound to like
to like measure where they're at and
their distances from each
other. Yeah. You know, their,
their languages are really incredibly
evolved and complex and they're really
beautiful.
And the fact that they're
like very friendly to human
beings and they're playful
with human beings.
But what's really freaky is there a rude
as shit to each other regularly rape.
Like they have these rape caves where
they'll tuck a female dolphin in and just
fucking rape raper forever.
They kill babies on a regular basis.
And then Orca is were killed
dolphins or cause we're talking,
we'll target dolphins and killed that
often talk. Yeah, we were talking about,
they found that dolphins can, um,
they have names for each other. Yeah,
I know. It's craziness to,
did you see that cartoon?
Someone did scientifically accurate.
Ducktails well,
you know Brian [inaudible]
it's like duck tales,
but the way ducks really are that
cartoon ducktails remember duck.
That's so cool. Yeah, it's so true.
It's really violent. And this in it.
Funny and disturbing. Is it violent?
Well, ducks ducks are violent.
Like all creatures are kind of fucked up.
I mean all creatures are not like
innocent and it's interesting,
but ducks,
ducks rape to Jamie
glasses over there,
right behind your butt or those dirty
glasses or clean glasses think they're
clean. Likud tell me
what's up. Don't look good.
Those look like clean glasses. Yeah.
Yeah. Bring those bitches over.
You've got some ice
scientific scientifically.
I think what they're doing right now
with the, with zoos and dolphins,
I think this is the last generation
that does that. That's my prediction.
My prediction is that they're going to
realize in a few years that what they're
doing is,
is really evil.
It's evil and it's unnecessary and
they're not allowed to do it anymore.
The United States is not allowed to kidnap
dolphins and take orchids from their
families.
They're not allowed to do it anymore,
so they have to be bred in captivity
or they have some other, like they're,
they're realizing, oh, this is the sign
talk.
Just going over our debt profile and
another duck ran over his fucking,
the dead stuck dumping piles.
Beds.
Why does don't lie pants and
they're shitting their pants?
Male ducks.
I wonder if,
uh,
various feminist movements have gotten a
hold of this making fun of rape because
this is spread rate. It's just quite rude.
I think this is rape culture. I am not.
I'm going to be awareness about the fact
that ducks are raping each other and
that it should be stopped. Oh that's
cool. You're cool man. Thank you.
It seems like a,
I mean the way this is this happening,
it's almost like a rape apologist video.
That's where they had a woman do it.
Well one, you know she's like the
uncle Tom of the feminist. She sang it.
She sang it. It's not a man. Ducks
rape. Can't believe you said that again.
You what do you,
what about trigger alert people to rape.
Why is that? Why the rave culture
man? I like. What are you,
what's your favorite part about rape
culture? Ah, that paintings the,
the way the guys breath smells.
I like going down. Yeah.
No I liked the symphonies. It's
like, it's funny how that culture,
I'll have a tiny bit please there.
You could. Tiny bit the culture there.
Well the idea of calling it
like rape culture, that's a,
some people protest that because when
you put something into that sort of a box
like oh it's rape culture.
Well then what is there a murder culture?
Cause they're Kinda is right.
There's a gun culture whenever you
want to like define something as being
negative, you call it a culture
that Paul was about full. Thank you.
What are we drinking here? I don't know.
That's a company who gave that to us.
I think somebody gave us
that whiskey while ago. Um,
I think this might've been the Armenians.
We got this Ronda Rousey. You want some?
Oh No, I'm good. Still drunk.
You're still drunk. How dare you.
Brian's live in the crazy rock
and roll life. He really is.
I really caught up to him like
over the last couple of years,
like if you follow his Instagram or his
Twitter while you guys were in saying
when they were in San Diego for comicon
it's all just drunken rampages and girls
sticking their butts out. The whole thing
was a mess. That was so much fun man.
Comic con you ever been to comic con?
I will do.
One time I even went down there was with
you is when we did shows last year at
American comedy club, but I didn't
go to the comic con thing at all.
It's too chaotic.
Well, like the guy from breaking
bad, uh, he wore a mask of them.
It leads guy wore a mask of his character
so nobody would know who he is. Yeah.
And it was like a super realistic mask
was kind of like mission impossible mass.
So he's like walking around and was
like, oh, can I get a picture with you?
He's like, yeah, you against
dope. And then, uh, uh, when
they had the, the panel,
they called his name and he
came up out of the audience and,
and he sat down and was
like, what the fuck? Who,
who's this weird guy with the mask on?
And he just takes off his mask and it's
so weird cause he's like taking off his
own face.
Oh yeah. Maybe I'll go next year. Yeah.
And check it out.
It seems like something you have to do.
I heard Patton Patent recorded
his, uh, his comedy special there.
You did, dude. I seriously, I went to me
and jam band wouldn't, it wasn't yo Benji.
Uh, like we went from the beginning
of the line and walk to see how far
it went and went around
the whole entire place.
Went down the street around this other
building a down this other street.
Like it was the longest line I've ever
seen for standup comedy or was the venue,
what was the venue? It was a, it was
a theater that was down the street,
like a big theater. I
don't know, but it was, uh,
it was the one that I did last time. Did
you go with, I didn't know the last time.
Now it's San Diego's bad ass. I like
it a lot. There's a lot of great spots.
I forget what the Pandora, I want to say
I did the Pandora. Yeah. Think that's it.
Yeah. It's a beautiful theater too.
It's pretty dope. Yeah. There's a,
there's a house of blues there that's a
great place to perform American comedy
company. Like it used to be that there
was no comedy clubs in San Diego.
There's today there's mad house right
down the street from that House and
American comedy company together.
And then there's the theaters to,
we used to be the San Diego had La Hoya.
They had the comedy store and that was it.
But now it's like this,
like a genuine comedy community down
there. Yeah. Fucking love it down there.
I love that. It's a comedy
club too, right next to Mexico.
American comedy companies
grade. Go to asco. Uh, no,
but Yoshi almost was it Yoshi?
Yoshi almost talked me into it because
I guess people are saying that it's not
as bad as everyone is saying. Like right
when you go over, you just get an attack,
seek tell him to take you to this one
place and like there's like 200 hookers
and you just pick which
ones do you want out? Dude,
let me just before anything on my show,
I was interviewing a disease specialists.
Right? I interviewed some new guy who
scared the fucking shit out of me. Oh,
there's a new form of gonorrhea that
they cannot cure the Philippines.
They're finding it in Southeast Asia and
this, this, this form of gonorrhea. Okay.
That's the warning shot folks.
It's making its way over here
and you can't cure it and
it kills a lot of people.
Good luck. So you just have like Green
Shit coming out of your Dick for life.
I don't know. I don't know what
happens. It's good question.
Rots off. Falls off it.
Yeah.
I don't know what happens.
I really don't know what happens when
someone says he can't cure gonorrhea.
That ain't good. That can't be good.
That's not good. No, that's fucked up.
That's scary.
One of the things about the show that's
been fucking terrifying is talking to
disease specialists.
Dunkin and I went to Galveston,
Texas and we went to this level four lab,
which is like the highest level.
That's like where they deal
with like Ebola and like,
you know hemorrhagic viruses
that those hemorrhagic flus,
they tear apart your body and you just
bleed out of every hole and you turn into
mush. Dude, I was scared to go.
I was scared to go and Duncan and
I missed our flight. So we went,
we had like zero hour sleep the next
day we slept for one hour flight.
Like just from talking
just from I think what,
where we weren't even stoned now.
We were just having fun talking.
We're just laughing at the airport,
at the airport, the airport,
drinking beer and eating pizza and talking
and then we like casually forget that
there's a time that flight's happen.
Well I was wrong.
I thought it was 20 minutes
later than it was and they,
it was 10 minutes before the flight they
had locked the doors and I was like,
oh no. Like why can, why don't you let us
on? Like we've already locked door. I go,
but it's right there.
You can't let us on. Like
is it that really that hard to
open the door? I'm not a terrorist.
I didn't like call your name over
the intercoms or maybe they did man.
I don't think so.
Cause he had to take a tram to this.
Yeah it was, it was a, this
was a crafty situation.
But the bottom line is Dunkin and I,
we waited at the airport and then we flew
there and then we went from there with
no sleep,
got some coffee and went to meet this
disease specialist at this creepy fucking
lab where they keep, you know, rabies,
this is, uh, this lab is a, this,
this lab is straight out of every
movie where like a plague starts.
It's the, it's like guarded,
it's you and it's got an, uh,
an outside shell around it.
It's got a shell that's basically around
another building that has within it
different security levels.
And in the deepest security levels,
that's where they keep
the hemorrhagic fever.
That's where they keep the Bulla forefoot
six cement walls and the whole
deal half of filters. Yeah,
it was really,
they showed us the filtration system.
I mean they really have it locked down,
but it's in Galveston,
Texas and it's word tornadoes.
Hurricanes hit like right next
to the ocean and they, they,
it's like all the good shit is way
up high. So if the water comes in,
theoretically the water will never
reach the areas where the uh,
the diseases are. Wow. But
it's just, oh, it's so crazy.
Like when you really stop
and think about what a,
what a gamble that is like Montana
used to be underwater. Did you,
did you know that like
the whole fucking thing?
He used to be under the
great western inland sea,
so they're just banking that Galveston
is going to stay above ground. Like what,
what if a massive shift in the,
in the earth's cross happens if there's
a giant earthquake right off the coast,
guess what? That fucker's
underwater now. Yup. I get how,
how well do you have that locked down?
They claim they claim is
totally locked down completely.
I was thinking about it and I was,
you know,
thinking of like the outrage of the light
and the Hubris and all that of having
like a zoo of deadly viruses.
But then what freaked me out even
more as I realize that's necessary,
we need that because of the gonorrhea
that you're talking about and all the
countless other things that are happening
all over the planet all the time.
That's some of that is definitely the
thing that creeped me out the most doing
this show was a bio at the
bar by apocalypse. Yeah.
That shit is real and scary and provable
and a matter of time and when you see
the look on these people's faces,
they look like people with a burden.
There are people who are operating under
the burden of the knowledge that it's
only a matter of time before the right
duck shit and the right farm yard and the
right kid eats that duct meat and that
kid sneezes on the right person and 20
million people die.
It's only a matter of time.
It's like the earthquake
that's going to come to la.
Like it's not a matter of if,
but when,
and these people are desperately trying
to understand how to create vaccines for
shit that maybe doesn't even exist
yet. That's scary man. Well there,
they've got ahold of it
so far. What's really,
it's it, it is scary,
but it's also really incredibly
fascinating that we're,
our bodies are essentially ecosystems
that we're not just a person.
You're a whole bunch of different
life forms coexisting together. Yeah.
And there there's more bacteria cells
in your body than there are human cells.
Yeah. Like did the whole thing
is it's a mass, a mass of life.
There's e coli and all this different
flora that lives on your skin.
And that's one of the
reasons why probiotics.
So I always see me drinking Kombucha.
I drink this stuff every day or drinking
like crazy and I never get sick.
Build your immune system as well.
It doesn't just build your immune system.
It actually creates troops.
It creates healthy bacteria troops
that fight off aggressively fight off
incoming troops. Wow. That's,
so if you come in contact with like
funky colds or weird showing your hands,
the acidophilus and um,
and probiotics,
various probiotics will actually go
after that stuff and keep it from taking
hold. Whereas if you have an
unhealthy skin flora and you know,
ironically what gives you an unhealthy
skin flora using antibacterial soap?
No Shit. Yep. Using antibacterial soap
is bad for you. I didn't cause, yeah,
you most stuff you can cure
with just soap and water.
Unless you're a surgeon and you're about
to cut someone's heart open and you're
worried about Murcia [inaudible]
what you really want is good soap,
just soap and there's in fact soap that
actually fosters healthy skin flora.
There's some stuff called defense soap
that a a lot of grapplers use and if you
go to defense soap.com they
sell this healthy soap.
It has tea tree oil and eucalyptus and
all these natural remedies for healthy
skin flora promotes healthy skin flora
and cleans off all the negative shit.
You shouldn't be fucking with a
antibacterial soap unless you have a real,
you know,
doctor prescribed.
That's crazy,
man.
I didn't know that because when I go to
the airport I'll buy one of those little
tubes and slather my hands.
That's okay.
That's okay. That's not that
bad, but putting it on your
hands, it's not that bad.
When you wash your body with it, that's
when shit gets weird. When, when you it,
you can wash your hands then a
bacterial soap and you'll be fine.
But regular old soap and water
will kill anything that's bad.
You should wash your hands,
wash your hands on a regular basis,
especially when you are touching
a lot of things in public places.
And then you touch your eyes, your face.
I mean that's how things get spread you.
But washing your hands just with
soap and water can fix most of that.
But when you wash your body
with antibacterial soap,
you really fuck up the whole like
ecosystem on the surface of your skin.
I knew a dude who had, um,
he had like chronic ringworm.
He started getting ringworm from grappling
and started getting it everywhere and
you know, uh, I think it was Eddie Bravo
school him on it who said like, okay,
what are you doing? Like how are
you getting this all the time? Like,
what are you taking? Do you use Lamisil?
Am like, oh, something that kills it.
Do you take probiotics? Like you
got to not use antibacterial soap.
You've got to figure out how to like bring
your body back to health because this
is like a symptom of an issue.
These,
what ringworm is,
is a,
an invading army and it's got a stronghold
in your system and as a strong in
your system because your system's week.
So let's figure out why your
systems a week. Like what is it?
And that's the holistic approach. They're
very few people take, they just go,
I'll go to put your man and bacterial
soap on his back to prom. Right.
It's not just that there's, you're,
you're a whole system, you know, it's,
but it's really hard for us to wrap our
hands because I'm not a system of me.
You're Duncan Trussell. That's, you know,
that's Brian. Like we're people, right?
I'm a person. I know who I am and you're
not. No, you're, you're, you're, you're,
there's like a consciousness
that's moving the school of cells,
you know, and the school of cells is
of, there's a lot of shit going on.
That's fucking crazy,
man.
That's a crazy thing to think about that
we're just like a tightly woven school
of bacterial fish swimming
through the coral reef of matters.
Do you one better the each individual
cells almost entirely space.
So we don't even know what the
fuck we are. We're just, we're,
we're this combination of different
cells that share some sort of a strange
relationship with each other,
you know, and each cell is
mostly just nothing. Yeah,
it's a harmony.
And by the way,
it's a harmony that is destined to fly
apart into a million pieces eventually.
That's the other, definitely. Maybe,
maybe the figure out a way around that
Daca Trussell maybe that's an what were
talking about when we did the,
the robot apocalypse show where we
deal with Robo sapiens. All these,
when we went to Dunkin and I and Ra went
to this global future 2045 conference
in New York City and met
with all these futurists.
Are we going to get in
trouble saying all this stuff?
I know we're supposed to keep
our lit or, well, we're not,
we're not giving away
any, um, any secrets.
We're just talking about
how bad ass it was.
That was bad conversations we've
got to have with these people. Yeah,
it was amazing. We're, we're,
we're, we're in strange times.
People strange fucking times and
getting stranger every God damn day.
Yeah. It's true. Every day it's
getting weirder and weirder.
Beautiful and weird and, and I wish,
it's just an interesting thing, man. I'll
tell you, if you keep doing this show,
man, you're going to stumble upon
something fucked up. I don't think so.
I think so. That's you,
man. You always go to that
dead babies,
Nancy grace,
you're going to stumble on
some demonic possession thing.
You're going to be in the woods.
You're going to find some people.
They're going to be sacrificing virgin.
You're going to have to make a decision,
man, and it's going to be like a
star trek thing or star craft thing.
You're going to have to move your dongle's
into a certain parents. Dongles out,
dare you.
There's no dongles and star starcraft.
Yeah. The angrier he got. Yeah. Oh, it
was real. It was real folks. It was real.
It was beautiful.
But it was real.
Duncan Trussell is back on economy horse
and he will be appearing tonight at the
Ice House was lovely comedy or something.
Know what this is going to be like
Thompson Guerra. Why do you say that?
How dare you? Don't be
negative. You creating your own
reality. This is the secret.
Okay. Yeah. I haven't been on
stage in two months. He used to see
every comic. I knew I been on
stage. It's going to be great.
It's going to be the
Greek side of my window
that hasn't been on stage
in what says what it says.
What if you haven't been on
stage and two months that sock.
Can you get a spanking
from the gods of comedy?
Come on.
We all know this.
I took three months off
once. Wow. Yeah, yeah.
Long time ago I got just, I was burnt
out and I just decided, you know what?
I'm in the middle of so much shit.
Let me just take some Tylenol and it was
the longest I'd ever taken off a comedy
and then I remember getting back on
stage. It was like, Oh, this is nice.
Like immediately fell right back into
it. I miss it. First setback was weird.
Second setback was comfortable.
Yeah Man, I'm, I'm, I'm excited
about it but I know I've got,
I've got to pay the piper a little
bit and I'm willing to pay the right.
You're still performing.
See that's one of the things that I've
found about doing podcasts and uh,
doing them on a regular basis.
Especially like you get used to
talking in front of people, you get,
you get you the, the like the
anxiety that fucks up your set,
that that's alleviated.
You're always going on these rants.
I mean you're doing these rants when we
do the podcast for the show in front of
like just the suits and the
camera people and the, the,
the folks that work on the show
and you're going right into it,
go right in the flow. You're not being
self conscious. You know, you're,
you're completely in the moment.
And I think a lot of that has to
do with doing a lot of podcasts.
Yes, for sure. It's just,
yes. It's definitely a skill
that you develop and you get,
you get, you get better at your right
man. It is a form of performance and it's,
uh, yeah, I love it. It's really fun.
It's a lot less anxiety
provoking then getting onstage,
but I'm excited about
getting on stage again.
I want to get back into walking
around the ice house, you know,
just like being in a comedy club, this
thing starts arising in me like, fuck,
I miss this man that it, but it, it, it
becomes such a huge part of your life,
you know? But it's like sometimes
you do have to take a break.
I had to take a break. I, there's just,
I couldn't go on stage after my mom died.
I was just too weird. It was
like, I just, I didn't, I didn't,
just didn't want to spend any
mental energy dealing with that.
I think I told you about the,
the time I went on stage after
Phil Hartman and died, well,
I had one of the worst sets in my life,
like you have to,
Phil Hartman died where
I fucked up and I, I, I,
I was just starting getting my stage legs
back under me and then I was at a gas
station. I ran into a friend
who's a police officer and uh,
he gave me some details about the case
that I didn't know. Yeah. And it was,
I'll spare everyone the more but details.
But it was enough to really
freak me the fuck out.
And then I went on stage and just,
I couldn't be funny.
It was impossible and I had nothing
funny to say. I just ate shit.
And I knew in the middle of it that I
was never going to pull myself out of it.
I knew I shouldn't have been up there.
I should have taken more time off,
you know, whatever I,
whatever amount of time,
I don't remember how many weeks it was.
I took her off. It just wasn't enough.
Sometimes I think you got to do that.
And I think in comedy sometimes a,
a more of a uh,
uh,
athletic mentality applied to it,
which is like you just got to punk,
keep constantly punching the bag
no matter what. No matter what,
just punched the bag no matter what,
just just go through it.
And I think if you're going to be
doing stand up for your whole life,
Shit's gonna happen.
That's gonna make you have to take
some breaks from time to time.
Well,
even in that as an athletic point of view
is a bad point of view because one of
the,
one of the key things to athletes is don't
get yourself in a Rut and keep going.
Recognize what you're doing,
step back, assess, reanalyze,
go back into it. And also if you get
injured, don't keep going. Blow rest up.
Okay. Give yourself some recuperation.
And I think that a, a life injury,
like you know,
losing a loved one that's a life injury
and you've got to recuperate from that
injury and you have to deal
with the emotional damage
the same way you deal with
the damage.
To a ligament or damage to a muscle.
Yeah, and it and it all and then you
can it grief. Grief has its own pattern.
It's really curious because you
can see that there's like a,
a cyclical thing where in like it's,
it's terrible in cycles,
but then the that gets better and better
and better and it's really interesting,
man. It's a very natural thing,
but I don't know how p I,
and I've heard of comics who after their
folks die, like you keep doing standup.
I just don't know how you do that.
It's like you got to sit on the
bench for a while and then you buy,
I just bought a bird feeder.
I bought bird feeders and just
sat on my porch and you know,
like I was like feeding or
right after it happened,
I was sitting on my porch and
I bird feeders and the birds,
it started showing up. I'm
like, ah, this is great man.
This is really nice and peaceful and birds
are showing up to the bird feeder and
then there's this lack in a fucking bird
flew into the window right in front of
me.
I'm like,
I can't escape death.
Kill the fucking bird. Stop
getting so comfortable, bitch.
And on that note, I love you
buddy. I love you too. Hey,
thanks for putting me on your show,
Joe. So cool. It's so cool having you.
You made the whole thing much better.
That's really fun. We had a good time,
as did Ari Shaffir. Uh, thanks to
legal zoom. Go to legalzoom.com.
Use the code name Brogue and save yourself
some money. Thanks also to stamps.com.
Use the code word, J, r e n,
get yourself a special offer.
Thank you to onnit.com go to o
n n I t and use the code name,
Rogan God. Damn. I say these same things.
So often it's impossible to do it any
other way. Folks. Use a code name brogue.
Stick it up your butt and um,
put mushrooms on it and it'll grow spores.
Those spores will take over the universe
and then those spores will eventually
be housed in Galveston, Texas
behind 15 miles of glass. We need,
that's what the earth is for humans.
We love the fuck out of you guys. Uh,
the West Coast version of, uh,
the new show, Joe Rogan questions.
Everything starts in six minutes. Hope
you enjoy it. If you don't enjoy it,
that's cool too. It's tough. It's tough
out there for a pimp. I'm not a pimp.
He's a pimp. You're a pimp too. Love
you guys. What does that even mean?
What a terrible way to end it.
We were doing so well and I just,
I ran out of words. Um, yeah. Thanks
everybody. We'll talk to you soon.
We'll see you next week and
I'll see you this weekend.
If you watch the UFC fights or if you
live in Seattle and you go into the more
theater hollow, bye. See you
soon. Love you a big kiss me mark.
Mm.